Das war's für heute.
.
so moin leute ich bin glaube ich ein bisschen früher als sonst aber ich bin schon wach
mir gedacht warum soll ich nicht einfach stream anschmeißen ich bin gerade aufgestanden also
muss ich erst mal ein bisschen auffahren bestes emote und nicht zu vergessen wupp arrive
richtig residenz lieber
so wollen wir den sab habe ich ja gar nicht übersehen vier monate massive subscriptions
ja mach ich auch nicht kannst du bitte noch mal kurz sagen wie du die mit dem pile flasht ja ich
hoffe du hast welcher wichtig man noch flaschen kann ich hatte letztes glück nimmst dieses
projekt hier klons dir das repo auf dem raspberry pi und fürs dann die die schritte aus das hier
und dann startest du das flaschen und gut ist das ist alles was du brauchst du musst
drei sachen ausführen das ist eigentlich relativ selbst erklären aber du musst du musst
dieses repo hier klonen auf den raspberry pi die voraussetzungen installieren ich glaube
hier sieht man es ja auch ist auch sogar eine anleitung wie das wie das funktioniert
das hier musst du eigentlich nur machen das ist das ist alles schwachsinn du musst
es klonen die die prerequisites installieren und dann start flaschen machen fertig das ist
alles jetzt sehr gut warum nicht das war von gestern weiß ich da habe ich ein bisschen
postchamp gespammt wo ist das problem ich verstehe das gar nicht warum geht man davon aus bei zu
viel postchamp spam geht es einem nicht gut warum nicht die eigentliche frage mein heroes gaming
livestream ah ja deswegen sind die emojis in chrome eigentlich immer noch kaputt
schauen wir mal kurz ja emojis im chrome kaputt und chrome kaputt mal gucken wie es im chrome aussieht
emojis im chrome kaputt ok firefox firefox geht glaube ich firefox benutzt ja anderes emoji zeug
habe ich mich eigentlich schon mal darüber ausgelassen wie bescheuert das eigentlich ist dass es
mindestens vier verschiedene standards gibt für farbige emojis weil man sich gedacht hat einer
einer reicht nicht das muss muss mehr sein ja hier geht's firefox gehts interessant chrome unterliegen
ja das weiß ich und die jungs gehts aber unter windows ist es in chrome anscheinend kaputt
kommen wir mal chrome im broken chrome just changed emojis to online
das ist doch ein bug oder ok das ist ein bug das heißt im nächsten chrome geht das dann ganz
wieder weil das wäre ziemlich hängen geblieben hätte man hätte man einfach color color emojis
kaputt gemacht also wenn das wirklich absicht wäre ziemlich bescheuert in der app wirklich
das ist eine gute frage ich gucke mal kurz in meine eigene twitch app rein ich habe noch nie
geschaut wie das in der app eigentlich aussieht das muss ich mir jetzt mal kurz angucken also
laut der twitch app bin ich noch nicht mal online also auf ios funktionieren die emojis
ohne problem im app titel genau apple ist übrigens einer der mitspieler bei color emojis adobe hat
was apple hat was mozilla hat was und ich glaube microsoft hat auch was es gibt mindestens vier
verschiedene standards zum speichern und letztendlich auch rendern am ende farbiger emojis ist richtig
hängen geblieben dazu kann man nur sagen weird champing ja das würde ich natürlich in der
heutigen zeit auch zutrauen wo youtube dislikes entfernt werden vielleicht hat sich ja jemand
offended gefühlt von emojis wenn man sich von allem offended fühlt dann fühlt man sich bestimmt
auch von emojis offended ja wahrscheinlich liegt es bei android ist ja das problem dann
hast du auch unterschiedliche android versionen bei manchen gehts bei manchen gehts nicht android
ist ja richtig viel build books was das angeht was vor und nachteil zugleich ist unter android
kannst du halt einfach viel tiefergehend was machen als unter ios gerade was automatisierung
angeht also muss man ehrlich sagen sowas wie tasker oder automate it oder was es da nicht
alles gibt oder es gibt ja sogar komplette linux thermux oder ne wie ist das so komplett linux
umgebung für android mit mit bash scripts und sonst was also was du da alles machen kannst
unter android das ist not even close mit berg dings ne wie heißt das snippets moment shortcuts
shortcuts heißt es unter ios jetzt habe ich es wieder shortcuts genau zwischenzeitlich
mal umbenannt früher hieß es workflow oder sowas dann hieß es shortcuts dann heißt es
shortcuts for siri und jetzt heißt es wieder shortcuts oder so keine ahnung aber es ist
wie gesagt also allein schon von von der policy bei apple dass du quasi 99 prozent der sachen
nur durch user interaktion starten kannst und nur ganz ganz wenige sachen für automatisierung
möglich sind als input zum beispiel zum beispiel ich glaube wlan join geht noch macht es das
unter android tatsächlich für automatisierung viel viel besser und ganz viel viel mehr machen
was aber die normalen user gar nicht brauchen also deswegen für 0 auf 15 user ist ios immer
noch ziemlich gut hat schon ich meine es hat ja auch seinen grund ich verwende auch hauptsächlich
ios aber da wo ich basteln muss ist es android eigentlich ganz einfach man sollte einfach das
verwenden wo das system am besten das unterstützt was man machen will oder am wenigsten dagegen
arbeitet was man machen will easy i f übrigens ich habe ein lustiges video gefunden wo man mal den
unterschied sieht wo ich euch mal kurz zeigen das ist ja nur eine minute 19 wo man schön
noch mal den unterschied sieht zwischen halbwegs realistischen sprüchen in battlefield 3 versus
cringe in battlefield 2 42 punkt euch das mal
get your shit together our asses are fucked up you hear me we are russians we don't fucking
lose black this is a battlefield 3 damit halt die ganze zeit geflucht und russ
fight for russia fight for your families that was all i am not overconfident i'm just better
than everyone else those cocksucker motherfuckers got actual that would make me shit my panties
oh you know i think i pulled something back there your russians pull your fucking thumbs
out of your asses and get the fucking battle back to them we are in the shithole unless
you move it now now move it now your fuck ass oh you know i think i pulled something
back there well well well that was fun come on you cocksuckers you want to live forever
think about what you're doing you dumb fucks you're shooting at your old man come on pups
buddy hop the fuck on man i felt that one of my left nut also das sind schon das ist
schon ganz schöner unterschied dazwischen oder aber leute ich ich wette mit euch wenn
battlefield 3 heute rausgekommen wäre mit diesen sprüchen es wären so viele leute
offended gewesen und der shitstorm auf twitter wäre riesig gewesen die wären so heftigst
getriggert das wäre nicht normal gewesen ich meine die waren damals gab es ja schon
die ein oder anderen leute die die sich darüber aufgeregt haben aber das war 2013 oder so
2021 ist es noch viel wäre das noch viel heftiger gewesen ne das kannst du heute nicht
mehr machen dementsprechend haben wir jetzt keine irgendwelche jetzt deswegen haben wir
jetzt irgendwelche cringy sprüche anstatt irgendwelche halbwegs realistisch angehauchte
military dinger ich mein mal realistisch betrachtet oder was was was ist wahrscheinlicher wenn
du irgendwo hinter einem felsbrocken sitzt und beschossen wirst ja dass die dann rum
schreien wie battlefield 3 oder dass die dass die sagen die feindinnen haben mich aufs
korn genommen oder irgendwie so was ich glaube du schreist eher rum wie in battlefield 3
also anders kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen ich glaube in der situation ist da kein platz
mehr für besonders korrekt weil wenn du gerade ein hinter weggeballert kriegst da wären
leute gedriggern die das game gar nicht spielen das richtig dritter ist eigentlich hauptsächlich
von leuten die sich da aufregen die gar nicht legenderweise damit was zu tun haben die sich
aufregen weil sich irgendjemand dem sie folgen auch aufregt und so was habt ihr das mitbekommen
von der einen auf twitter die behauptet hat dass sie twitch angeschaltet hat und innerhalb
der ersten zehn minuten hat sie quasi dreimal das n wort und und äh äh zweimal das c wort
und und und sonst was gehört das mittlerweile ist ja das wirre du darfst die worte noch
nicht mal mehr aussprechen um zu sagen um was es eigentlich geht aber ich glaube ich
glaube jeder weiß was ich meine und das hat sie geschrieben auf twitter und da haben halt
ganz viele leute geantwortet so nach dem motto ja beweise glaube ich nicht und dann haben
die den ähm und dann haben die dann riesen riesen fast aufgemacht wie wie dreist denn
die leute bitteschön sein können beweise zu verlangen da habe ich mir auch gedacht
leute wo leben wir dann eigentlich ich meine random einfach mal sagen auf twitter wird
laufen das n und c wort getroppt ohne beweise ist schon ziemlich weit aus dem fenster gelehnt
weil ich glaube twitter ne nicht twitter was laberchen twitch schwein nicht twitter twitch
auf twitter geschrieben über twitch dass auf twitch quasi laufen das n und c wort getroppt
werden würde und frauenfeindlich und sonst was und man muss halt mal echt sagen twitch
ist da mittlerweile sehr restriktiv also wenn du über manche themen auf twitch reden willst
müsstest du müsste dich ja eigentlich eher schon über klick lauter austauschen also
besprechen anstatt jetzt wirklich über das an sich ja damit das überhaupt noch geht
und nicht direkt gebannt wirst und die hat keinerlei beweise gepostet und twitch ist eh
schon sehr restriktiv was das angeht und dann wollten die leute beweise haben haben gesagt
ja hier glauben wir nicht post post sogar xqc hat irgendwas geschrieben in der richtung
proof or didn't happen oder sowas proof or delete post oder irgendwie sowas hat er gepostet
und haben es die leute aufgeregt wie viel wie kann man eigentlich nur proof verlangen dafür
das ist auch was was ich teilweise nicht verstehe ja wie kann man beweise für was verlangen
das ist ja das ist ja 2021 nicht mehr angesagt das reicht wenn es jemand sagt und das war
dann auch riesen riesen shitstorm auf twitter die einhabende haben ihr das geglaubt war
ich glaube das persönlich nicht weil wie gesagt twitch ist äußerst restriktiv und du wirst
instant reportet und fliegt instant raus wenn du was in dieser richtung sagt mittlerweile
ist der post gelöscht also das war auch wieder so ein ding man hat sich da schon also die
schieden sich teilweise die leute richtig eigentoren heutzutage mit über mit diesem
übertriebenen empören über alles und wenn es halt grad nichts gibt muss man was erfinden
um sich drüber zu empören dabei wenn man ehrlich ist gibt es genug sachen die scheiße
laufen auf der welt worüber man sich empören kann da müsste man sich gar nichts ausdenken
naja was können wir uns jetzt hier angucken was ist das
der lenkt jetzt gleich wenn eine kurve kommt oder also wenn er so krass lenkt dann fliegt
er dann fliegt das auto erstmal weg
aber ist cool das war schon 2017 dass er das on the fly erkennt ist schon nicht schlecht
ja das ist ja nichts neues guck mal da zeigt euch das gestern das gleiche was ich euch
gestern auch gezeigt habe guck hier ach guck mal es gibt noch einen anderen spot da oben
ok ne das hier genau was spielspaß zerstören freischalten ist für mich kein spiel quasi
im battlefield also in dem battlefield auf jeden fall nicht außerdem hat das auto in
die falsche richtung gelingt ja das kommt auch noch dabei
regex in 100 sekunden ich glaube das letzte was ich mir heute morgen angucken muss ist
ein regex tutorial doch nein nein nein wir gucken uns jetzt nicht an
also ich predicte jetzt mal der schaut das schloss einfach nur einmal durchdringend an
und dann gehts auf
ja gut niemand macht die schlösser ja auch hier auf mit durchschneiden der kommt wahrscheinlich
jetzt an mit seinem selbst hergestellten cylinder cracking tool und dreht dreimal rum und es
auf oh das hätten sie das hätten sie nicht reinschreiben sollen
ich wusste dass er irgendwie mit einem eigenen tool ankommt das ist immer so geil der hat
immer irgendwelche super special tools wo er dreimal rumdrehen muss und dann ist auf
die wunderschöne
10 fühlt sich an, als wäre es in einem Gaten.
9 ist Binding.
Ein kleiner Klick dort.
8 ist Binding.
Ein Klick von 8.
7 fühlt sich an, als wäre es in einem Gaten.
6 fühlt sich an, als wäre es in einem Gaten.
5 fühlt sich an, als wäre es in einem Gaten.
Und wir haben es offen.
Okay, Leute.
Das braucht natürlich spezielle Tools und Fähigkeiten, um es zu holen.
Aber für diejenigen, die es haben, ist das nicht so viel eine Herausforderung.
In jedem Fall ist das alles für heute.
Wenn ihr irgendwelche Fragen oder Kommentare habt, lasst sie in den Kommentaren.
Wenn ihr dieses Video gefallen habt und mehr von uns sehen wollt, dann abonniert.
Und wie immer, einen schönen Tag!
Es gibt auch lustige Lockpicking-Lawyer-Parody.
Den fand ich eigentlich ganz witzig.
Hier, das da. Weiß ich, ob wir das schon mal geguckt haben.
Das ist halt einer, der ihn nachmacht, aber der macht ihn wirklich gut nach.
Das ist der Lockpicking-Lawyer und heute habe ich ein sehr spezielles Video für euch.
Also der trifft auch die Tonlage richtig gut.
Normalerweise gibt es einen Puzzle, den ich lösen soll.
Aber heute habe ich einen Puzzle gegen meinen eigenen Willen eingeführt.
Ich wurde von einem seltsamen Puppet auf der Telefonie informiert,
dass es eine Verschwindung braucht, um auszudrücken.
Und hier sind die Regeln.
Es gibt einen Explosiv neben meinem Arm auf einem Timer,
der mir sorgt, dass meine Lockpicking-Tage über sind, wenn ich nicht in der Zeit rauskomme.
Um auszudrücken, muss ich aber mit meiner Hand drunter drücken,
was den perfekten guten Zustand für einen langweiligen Abus-Padlock zerstört.
Das wird nicht passieren.
Also müssen wir auszudrücken, Lockpicking-Lawyer-Style.
Ich habe sehr schnell gemerkt, dass diese Schraube mit sehr seriösen Sicherheitsbedingungen gefüllt ist.
Einer davon ist das Fakt, dass mein linker Arm nicht komplett geschnitten ist.
Und der andere ist das.
Ein unglaublich teuerer, chinesischer Padlock.
Ich könnte es wahrscheinlich öffnen, wenn ich darüber nachdenke.
Aber wir werden...
Das würde ich ihm tatsächlich zutrauen, dass er einfach nur dran denken muss, dass das Schloss aufgeht.
Das geht auch.
... und wir werden es öffnen.
Ich habe diesen Papierklipp aus dem Boden und die Bänden so.
Also, los geht's.
Leider habe ich keinen Tension-Wrench.
Also muss ich meinen Thumbnail als Tension-Wrench benutzen.
Okay, wir haben eine Bindung.
Zwei ist gesetzt.
Das Gleiche auf drei.
Klick auf vier.
Das Gleiche auf fünf.
Okay, zurück zu Beginn.
Eine ist gesetzt.
Zwei ist gesetzt.
Und los geht's.
Wir haben die Schraube geöffnet.
Die Schraube ist geöffnet.
Und so.
In ca. 30 Sekunden ist die Schraube komplett nicht funktionierbar.
Und jetzt ist es nur ein Thema, die Schraube auszuweichen.
Mal schauen, ob das Gerät sicher ist.
Und wir sind fertig.
Okay, Fox.
Siehst du, diese Schraube bietet sehr wenig Sicherheit, wenn es um die Schrauben geht.
Diese Schraube würde ich nicht empfehlen,
wenn du für Nähe-Death-Experienzen suchst.
In jedem Fall ist das alles, was ich heute für dich habe.
Wenn du Fragen oder Kommentare über diese Schraube haben möchtest,
schreib sie in die Kommentare.
Wenn dir dieses Video gefallen hat,
und du möchtest mehr Liken sehen,
dann vergiss mir Surelyissent, direkt ins Cinema.
Sieht very well.
Wir haben die Schraube failing.
Und diese Schraube ist völlig weddli직.
So, alle Schrauben sind klar fashionably,
Aber machen sie das?
Weiß ich nicht, wie sie das machen. Ich habe jetzt nichts zugefunden
Erster Reddit-Kommentar, postet mal, postet mal Link
Dann können wir uns das auch angucken
Jetzt gibt's einfache Übungen
Als wie es jetzt in Battlefield 2042 drin ist, verfolgst du die Schach-WM ein bisschen?
Nee, ich hab letztens einen Livestream aufgemacht, weil der empfohlen wurde, aber ich hab mit
Schach nichts am Hut.
Es war ja kurze Zeit auch mal Twitch-Meter, dass alle Schach gespielt haben, aber das
ist wieder vorbei.
Twitch Schach-Meter ist vorbei.
Im Discord hat jemand gepostet, ich soll mir das Video angucken, weil hier irgendwie einer
zeigt was er mit seinen 30.000 Servern im Keller macht.
Skippen wir aber durch, weil 30 Minuten ist ganz schön lang.
Freust du dich auf Breath of the Wild 2?
Mal gucken, ich warte es ab, ich warte es ab bis es raus ist, falls Nintendo es irgendwann
schafft es die nächsten 10 Jahre rauszubringen.
So, weil der Typ hat letztens ein Video gemacht, das haben wir uns im Stream angeguckt, wo
er seine Server im Keller gezeigt hat und ich hab mich dann halt noch gewundert, warum
der so viele netten Kisten hat, was der damit alles macht, weiß ich nicht ob man das insgesamt
mal sieht.
Also der hatte da ja schon einiges an Virtualisierungskram und sowas, ne, der hat hier unten irgendwie
den Storage-Cluster oder irgendeinen Storage, dann hat er zwischendrin, ich hab mir gefragt,
was macht der damit und anscheinend, jetzt hat mir das jemand in Discord gepostet, ein
Video gemacht, was er damit macht, da bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Wir werden da ein bisschen durchskippen, weil die kompletten 38, 31 Minuten muss nicht sein.
Ja, genau.
Es ist im Vergleich zu anderen natürlich gar nicht so übertrieben, es gibt ja Leute,
die haben zwei komplette Fullsize-Racks voll im Keller stehen, haben wir ja gestern gesehen,
ich weiß nicht ob ich hier noch drinne hab, Punkt App oder, hier das da, das da hat gestern
jemand geschickt, das steht wohl bei ihm im Keller, aber ja gut, naja, geht auch noch
ein bisschen härter als das, was ich hab, vor allem, was ich interessant finde, ist
eine Konsole mit Windows drauf, was ja schon an sich ziemlich Paint-Champ ist, aber ansonsten
ist das hier natürlich nochmal übertrieben, also sind halt zum größten Teil, also das,
wo man hier, hier sieht man vergessen, das da oben sieht aus wie ein CRT bisschen, weil
auch das Spiegel vorne, aber vielleicht ist es auch ein Safe, ich hab keinen Schimmer,
es sieht halt ein bisschen aus wie von Ebay, ältere Server hat wer von Ebay gekauft.
Warum man nicht aufräumen, weiß ich, das funktioniert doch, die nächste Frage ist
ja auch, warum raume ich meinen Desktop nicht auf, man findet doch alles, also wenn man
keine Probleme hat, was zu finden, macht es auch keinen Sinn aufzuräumen. So und jetzt
gucken wir mal an, das ist das natürlich klein dagegen. Laptop auf der Konsole? Stimmt, das
kann tatsächlich ein Laptop auf der Konsole sein, ja das stimmt schon, das ist gar keine
Konsole, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Dell-Server, oder irgendwas, ich erkenne das Slogan halt
nicht, der einfach aus dem Rack raus steht, wo er sein Notebook drauf gelegt hat. So und
jetzt gucken wir mal, was er mit seinem Mini-Rack hier macht. Ja, lass mich raten, ok, ich rate
mal, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich rate mal, er hat wahrscheinlich jede Menge Virtualisierungszeug,
warum auch immer, müssen wir gleich mal gucken und wahrscheinlich, ich würde da jetzt einfach
mal drauf tippen, dass die Hälfte Verwaltungsinfrastruktur ist, die man eigentlich gar nicht bräuchte,
das rate ich jetzt einfach mal, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt, aber das ist mir gerade auch
auf Reddit, so bei Self, weiß nicht, ob jemand so dieses Self-hosted Reddit ab und zu mal
liest, das Subreddit, dieses Self-hosted Subreddit, die Leute, da sind auch teilweise ein bisschen
merkwürdig drauf, die hosten dann irgendwie Nextcloud und ein Wiki, aber zusätzlich haben
sie noch ein Container zum Dashboard generieren, ein Container für Portäner, ein Container
für Monitoring, ein Container für Verwaltungssoftware XY, die man braucht, um die anderen Container
dann wiederum zu verwalten, ein Container für Notifications, also sprich, die haben
zweimal Software laufen, die sie brauchen und achtmal Sachen laufen, die quasi zur
Verwaltung der Verwaltung für die Verwaltung der zweimal Software-Dinger ist, das ist
teilweise einfach bescheuert, wie das die Leute machen, die machen sich einfach unnötig
Arbeit, deswegen würde ich jetzt mal drauf tippen, dass das hier ähnlich ist, aber mal
gucken.
Achja, das haben auch viele Leute, ich hab's mittlerweile nicht mehr, weil du Twitch Werbung
nicht mal gescheit bloggen kannst und ich hab mittlerweile YouTube Premium und auf Desktop
hab ich Adblocker im Browser, also den einzigen Fall, für den ich das brauchen würde, ist
auf den Tablets und auf den Smartphones auf normalen Webseiten, warum einfach ein Kubernetes
am Start, naja gut, werden wir gleich sehen, Kubernetes Cluster, warum ja, um ein Kubernetes
Cluster zu haben, Chat, was ist besser als ein Kubernetes Cluster, ein oder nicht zwei
Kubernetes Cluster, wobei man könnte auch sagen, ein größerer Kubernetes Cluster,
wenn ihr nach einem
es noch gibt. Es gab mal Rancher OS, es gab mal Core OS, Core OS gibt es jetzt nicht mehr,
das haben sie unbedingt in Flat-K, weil, keine Ahnung, weil. So, TrueNAS, gut, denn NAS an
sich ist nicht verkehrt, wobei ich halt ganz ehrlich sagen muss, wenn man eh schon eine
Kiste laufen hat, man muss es nicht übertreiben, jeder x-beliebige Ubuntu-Server mit einem
Hammer drauf reicht als Fileserver, was brauchst du da sonst noch großartig? Longhorn, keine
Ahnung was das ist, das war mal ein Codename für Windows Vista, glaube ich. Traffic, habe
ich auch laufen für Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate, Stels. Ja, ich habe die Secrets, ich habe
die Secrets auch, ich habe die Secrets glaube ich so gehardcoded noch drin in der Docker
Post, warum nicht. So, Unify-Controller habe ich auch am Start. Craylog sehe ich bei mir
im privaten Einsatz überhaupt keinen Sinn dafür, weiß nicht, Chat, vielleicht seht
ihr das anders, aber, weiß nicht so, Logs einsammeln, Log-Analyse, wüsste ich nicht,
wozu ich das im privaten Einsatz bei mir brauche. Ich bin eh, ich bin eh dabei permanent bei
mir daheim, so wenig wie möglich mittlerweile noch laufen zu haben, weil, je weniger man
da offen hat, umso weniger muss man sich darum kümmern. So, Proxmox, dreimal, weil, keine
Ahnung, Nutt, das ist, das hat mit Nuss glaube ich nichts zu tun, ich glaube das ist für
USVs, ich glaube das ist für, ehm, wie heißt es auf Deutsch, wie heißt es nochmal auf
Deutsch, unterbrechbare Stromversorgung, und nee, uninterruptible, wie heißt das nochmal
auf Deutsch, unterbrechungsfreie Stromversorgung, so, so, ja, ja, genau, genau, ja, ich glaube,
ich glaube, ehm, dafür, das ist ein UI dafür, das ist der Nuss-Server, das ist dann, gehört
auch, warum das doppelt drin ist, keine Ahnung. So, warum man Portainer nochmal oben drauf
braucht, keine Ahnung, er hat hier einen Kubernetes-Cluster, kann er sein Zeug da drin laufen lassen und
hier für einzelne Container, weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das hier das GUI für seine
anderen Container, weiß ich, also ich finde, gerade wenn man ein halbwegs ordentliches
Docker-Compose-File hat für 4-5 Services, braucht es eigentlich kein Portainer mehr
oben drauf. Hat jemand einen Plan, warum, was für Portainer spricht, versus irgendwie
ein Git-Shit-eingechecktes Docker-Compose-File, jetzt, wo Docker-Compose sogar quasi im Docker-Core
mit drinne ist, was ich selbst gar nicht wusste bis vor zwei Tagen.
Sub-GUI, weißt du, hat das vielleicht irgendwelche Vorteile, was Backups angeht oder so, ich
muss gestehen, ich hab Portainer nie wirklich verwendet. Kann man mit Portainer einfacher
komplette Container-Backupen oder so vielleicht, oder Snapshotten oder sowas, wobei eigentlich
muss Container nicht Snapshotten. Netzwerke managen, gut, das Problem hab ich
nicht beim Docker-Compose, ich manage da keine großartig unterschiedlichen Netzwerke. Ja,
gut, was haben wir sonst noch? Grafana, gut, das hab ich auch am Start für die Heizung
und für auslaufende Zertifikate und Speicherplatz und sowas, halt da, wo es sinnvoll ist. Pie-Hole,
sogar drei Stück, weil einer nicht reicht, ja, kann man machen, muss man nicht machen.
Dann hat er irgendeinen Homebridge, dann hat er Draco-IPME, achso, das sind die Management-Interfaces
seiner POXMOX Server wahrscheinlich. Ich überleg grad, für was IPME steht, also bei IPME,
ich hab keine Ahnung, Baseport-Management, nee, Platform-Management vielleicht? Platform-Management,
ich muss mal kurz gucken, für was steht, IPME, Intelligent Platform-Management-Interface,
ja, alles klar, gut, wer weiß sowas auch aus dem Kopf. Das ist quasi das Management-Interface
für seine POXMOX-Dinger. Broadlink-Control, okay, das hab ich nicht, ich hab zwei Broadcom-IR-Dinger
am Start, aber die hab ich, da gibt's auf GitHub so Custom-Software-Firmen, die zu bedienen.
Blacks, seh ich überhaupt keinen Sinn drin, hab ich nicht. Hier bin ich mir nicht sicher,
was das ist, das hab ich schon mal gehört. Weiß jemand aus dem Kopf, was das ist? Min.io,
sagt mir was, ich kann's aber grad nicht zuordnen. Simples Monitoring, Link zu seinem YouTube-Channel,
das ist wichtig, der muss ins Dashboard rein und Schlink, weiß ich nicht, was das ist,
was Schlink ist, schau ma mal. Ach, jetzt hat er rausgescrollt, okay, Schlink. Schlink,
was ist Schlink? Schlink, Url-Shortener, das ist ein Url-Shortener. Und bei der Erklärung
von Min.io, was ist das gewesen? High Performance Kubernetes Native Object Storage, also quasi
S3 für Kubernetes, oder wie? Einfach, einfach drei Cluster-Nodes, warum?
Weil's geht. Das ist wichtig, das ist das allerwichtigste, dass die Dinger coole Namen
haben. Meine Kisten heißen nach Twitch-Emails. Also die neueste Kiste im Keller, die an der
Tür-Gegensprecher-Lage erkennt, wenn geklingelt ist, heißt beispielsweise Elevenhead, warum
auch immer. Das erstbeste Twitch-Emote, ich glaube, es gibt noch nicht mal das Emote
wie Elevenhead, aber so heißt es halt. Alter! Und gar nicht mal so viel. Wisst ihr, was
das Problem daran ist? Das ist ein cooles Setup, ich sag ja da gar nichts dagegen. Das
ist ein cooles Setup und das funktioniert bestimmt auch gut. Aber zwei Probleme, die
ich mit solchen Setups habe, warum ich es persönlich nicht mache, ist, das erste ist,
es ist ganz schön verwaltungs-, gut, Stromkosten, so meine ich jetzt gar nicht. Es ist, nur
aus technischer Sicht, es ist relativ verwaltungsintensiv. Also du musst auch viel dir merken, wenn
du da was machen musst. Wenn du nicht täglich daran bist, ZFS zu administrieren oder sowas,
du vergisst die Sachen ja auch relativ schnell. Vielleicht liegt das auch an mir, aber wenn
du Sachen nicht täglich machst, musst du immer nachgucken. Du brauchst entweder ein
ziemlich ausführliches Wiki oder du musst halt permanent Sachen nachgucken. Deswegen
bin ich mittlerweile so oft im Prip möglichst die simpelste Technik und davon möglichst
wenig, wenn ich was dauerhaft laufen lassen will bei mir daheim. Und das nächste ist,
warum ich das nicht haben will, wenn was kaputt ist, fickst du dich dumm und dämlich. Wer
von euch weiß denn beispielsweise, wie man wirklich ZFS repariert, wenn man was im Arsch
ist? Ich wüsste es nicht. Wer von euch weiß oder hat da viel Erfahrung mit einen Proxmox
Cluster zu fixen, wenn er mal aus irgendwelchen welchen Wiegearten, Gründen nicht geht, also
sprich rausfinden, woran es liegt und es dann beheben? Keine Ahnung, ich wüsste es nicht.
Das heißt, du hast zwar eine theoretisch höhere Verfügbarkeit oder eine theoretisch höhere
Ausfallsicherheit, aber praktisch gesehen kann es durchaus sein, dass dir gerade das,
die gestiegene Komplexität letztendlich Probleme macht versus einem super simplen Setup mit
einer Platte, die sich nachts per ersten Spiegel zum Beispiel. Deswegen bin ich kein Fan mehr
von so ultrakomplexen Setups daheim. Der arbeit sieht das alles ganz anders aus. Wichtig,
wichtig, wichtig, wichtig, die Dinger brauchen coole Namen.
Warum? Okay, wir abwarten.
jetzt kommt wieder die Sache. Er braucht eine dritte Kiste, weil Kubernetes das von
der Logik her gerne hat. Also ein Quorum ist dafür da in der Regel, dass man entscheiden
kann, welcher der Cluster-Nodes-Master-Node ist. Das hast du bei Filesystems auch, das
hast du bei Datenbanken auch. Irgendeiner muss ja entscheiden, welcher der Cluster-Knoten-Master
wird, wenn die sich zum Beispiel untereinander nicht mal sehen oder wenn irgendwas ausfällt.
Und ihr seht, jetzt braucht er schon eine dritte Kiste, einfach nur vom Design her,
die er normalerweise wahrscheinlich gar nicht bräuchte.
Bestimmt, bestimmt liegen da nur legal übertochend runtergeladene Linux ISO-Images drauf.
Auf was wartet er? Ich hab's nicht verstanden, auf was wartet er?
Was? TrueNAS? Was? Die haben noch was Neues? Was für ein Ding? Das heißt wusste ich noch
gar nicht. TrueNAS scale. Aha. Haben die noch was Neues? Hyperconverged storage that scales
up or out. Alles klar. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Eine hyperkonvergente Storage-Lösung, die
hoch und raus skaliert. Was auch immer, genau. Ja, gut. Blablabla.
Okay. Was ist denn da alles drauf?
Übrigens, das ist tatsächlich sinnvoll die Festplatten so zu beschriften. Ich kann euch
sagen warum. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das die Seriennummer oder das Ende der Seriennummer
von den Platten ist. Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal. Weil die Sache ist die, wenn euch unter
Linux eine Platte abkackt. Das System weiß ja nicht, das ist die Platte, die in Slot 1,
2, 3, 4, die in Slot 5 steckt. Das weiß das System nicht. Das sagt euch dann Platte ist
ausgefallen, dann könnt ihr die Seriennummer nachgucken. Und dass ihr die Seriennummer
wisst, müsst ihr es vorne drauf schreiben. Das ist das coole an so fertigen NAS-Gehäusen,
die noch so out of band, wie heißt das so? SGPIO oder sowas. Es gibt so ein extra Kabel,
manchmal mit einem extra Protokoll drüber. Manche Mainboards, gerade auch teurere Storage-Geschichten
haben dafür Anschluss. Da kann quasi dann dein Betriebssystem kommunizieren mit dem
Chassis, wo die Platten drinstecken, die auch die LEDs steuern und sowas. Da könnte dann
quasi wirklich das Lidong sagen, hey, das ist Nummer 3 oder so oder Nummer 11. Was macht
der Herr dann mit dem ganzen Speicher? Das ist für sein Kubernetes und sein Virtualisierungsding,
was auch immer.
Aber TrueNAS ist verbunden mit dem Schiff und der Schiff hat 8TB-Drives drin. Diese 8TB-Drives
machen den Pool, den ihr hier seht. Ich habe einen großen CFS-Pool für jetzt. Dieser Pool
hat sechs Drives und sie sind alle 8TB-Drives. Diese Disken sind in einer RAID Z2 konfiguriert,
also gibt es mir viel Parade und auch einiges Performance. Und in diesem Pool habe ich
einen generischen für NFS, einen für S3, einen für Kubernetes, einen für Longhorn
und dann einen großen ICP-Pool. Also das ist wahnsinnig komplex für so ein halbes Setup.
Das ist interessant, aber was ich finde interessant ist all die Storage-Services, die ich runne.
Ich habe eine Entscheidung vor einiger Zeit gemacht, dass TrueNAS nur Storage für mich
verwendet wird. Keine Jails, keine Plugins, nichts mehr. Nur Storage. Aber das ist nicht
richtig.
Unraid ist glaube ich mehr so eine Mischung aus einem NAS- und Proxmox, was ich da bisher
gesehen habe. Das geht eher in die Richtung von dem, was du auf so einem Synology-NAS hast,
also quasi so ein Verwaltungsgui mit NAS. Ich kann dir aber dazu nichts sagen. Ich habe
es noch nicht verwendet und ich habe auch nicht Force zu verwenden, ich wüsste nicht
wozu.
Black Storage habe ich das richtig gehört. Darf man das heutzutage noch so nennen?
Das Apple? Ja. Alter, but why? Guck mal, Apple, Falschergedunst, ISCSE, NFS, Samba-Stells,
S3, nebenbei macht da anscheinend noch R-Sync, keine Ahnung. Alter, da brauchst du ja quasi
jemand, der sich um dieses Setup den ganzen Tag kümmert, der sonst nichts anderes macht.
Da kannst du dir ja quasi einen Admin einstellen, nur dafür.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen AHCI und RAID? Boah, ich bin jetzt bei solchen Sachen
nicht so der wahnsinnige Experte. AHCI ist glaube ich die Art und Weise, wie du SATA
Sachen ansprichst, so quasi dieser SATA-Control, also diesen ganzen SATA, Satz von SATA-Kommandos
und RAID ist ja was komplett anderes. RAID ist wie du Daten quasi aufsplittest auf mehrere
Festplatten. Also es ist vom Ansatz her eigentlich was komplett anderes.
Okay, jetzt der automatische Blocklist.
Naja, bei so vielen Kisten würde ich auch mit rechnen, dass er laufend irgendwas DNS
Fragen macht. Also ich hatte mal vor einer Weile verglichen.
Piehole versus, was war das andere? Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie das heißt ehrlich
gesagt, Home-DNR, ne wie ist das andere denn? Edgard, genau. Und ich muss sagen, Edgard
Home ist das glaube ich, genau. Und ich muss sagen, insgesamt hat mir Edgard tatsächlich
besser gefallen. So rein erster Eindruck, ich habe beides nicht
lange verwendet. Also würde ich, ach guck mal wir haben sogar
ein Kommando dafür. Null, guck mal der Chat weiß es wieder.
Chat kennt sogar die Chat-Kommandos dafür. Guck mal, da steht sogar mein Fazit noch
drinnen. Siehst du mal, was wir nicht alles haben
hier im Chat. Big Brain Chat, da sieht man mal, dass ich
die Prime-Subs ausgezahlt habe. Zumindest hat mir persönlich Edgard besser
gefallen.
Das ist fast resolution, I can use it for local DNS and it helps keep my network safe
by blocking unwanted domains. Now if you noticed, I actually have three
pie hole instances here and I do run three instances of pie hole. Kind of odd, I know,
but I do. So pie hole two is another instance and pie
hole three is another instance. I just said that, but they are another instance. These
are actually load balanced though. So I have a floating IP or a VIP and these two are load
balanced to another IP that is my secondary DNS. So technically my secondary DNS is backed
by two DNS servers. Ja, als geht ihm der pie hole kaputt und er
braucht einen ausfallssicheren internen DNS. Na klar, na klar. Wisst ihr was ich viel spannender
finde ist? Wie synkt er das untereinander? Weil der sagt ja, er hat eine Liste mit internen
Domainnamen. Das heißt, die muss er von Hand pflegen zwischen den ganzen Instanzen. Jedes
Mal, wenn er einen Eintrag macht, muss er die von Hand auf allen drei machen oder kann
sich das irgendwie synken?
Okay, da hat das quasi Architektur oder Infrastruktur übergreifend gemacht. Das kann man machen,
das wäre mir persönlich deutlich zu viel Aufriss für daheim, aber das kann man machen, klar.
Deswegen, deswegen habe ich meinen DNS der internen Namensauflösung gemacht einfach
auf meinem Mikrotikrouter drauf. Wenn der kaputt ist, geht eh nix mehr, da brauche ich
auch kein DNS. Ich nehme einfach zum Namensauflösung den billig DNS, der auf meinem Mikrotikrouter
drauf ist und sollte ich mal wirklich Adblock oder sowas machen wollen, ja gut, dann würde
ich halt noch zusätzlich noch das ganze über irgendeinen Pi-Hole schleifen. Ah, jetzt
wissen wir es, Gravity Sync. Okay, jetzt hat er meine Frage ja schon beantwortet.
Ja, warum nicht? Wollte ich, wollte ich nicht, wollte ich nicht, ich bin da mit meinem billig
Mikrotikrouter und den Ubiquiti Access Points eigentlich ganz glücklich. Ich habe hier
eine Mischung aus allen möglichen, ich habe Netzwerk, Equipment habe ich hauptsächlich
Mikrotik und Ubiquiti, ich habe noch einen alten TP-Link Access Point irgendwo rumstehen,
funktioniert eigentlich alles ganz gut zusammen.
Ja, den UniFi habe ich auch verlassen bei Reply laufen und Brotzimmer.
Ich habe
Unify-Protekt. Ich werde mit Unify-Protekt anstecken, bis etwas falsch geht oder mich verletzt zu wechseln.
Nächster Punkt ist die Kontainerisierung.
Ich habe zwei verschiedene Produkte und zwei verschiedene Kontainerisierungsplattformen verwendet.
Man darf nicht vergessen, er hat hier sein ganzes Virtualisierungstelz und zusätzlich hat er noch irgendeinen Kubernetes-Cluster und zusätzlich noch irgendein Portäner-Zeug zu managen.
Der will es echt wissen.
Ich mache das jetzt. Ich beginne mit dem ersten, das ist Rancher und Kubernetes.
Ah nee, Rancher hat er auch noch.
Hey Leute, ich sag euch mal eins. Wenn da, wenn da mal was kaputt ist, der braucht ne Woche bis es wieder läuft.
Da sind so viele Sachen, die schief gehen können und so viele Sachen, wo du erst im Zweifelsfall merkst, dass es da ist, wenn es kaputt ist, dann ist es komplett ripp.
Alter.
Ja, aber es ist ja schön und gut, wenn er das alles laufen hat. Die Frage ist ja eher, was hat er denn da drauf laufen, dass es sich überhaupt lohnt, es zu haben?
Oh, der Chat, der Chat sagt gerade oder einer im Chat sagt, er ist komplett anti-Smart-Home-Gedöns. Ja, deswegen holt man sich ja auch kein fertiges China-Chinesen-Zeug, sondern macht das so weit wie möglich selbst, dass man weiß, was passiert.
Ich mein, kommt mal alles, was man hier sieht, ist nur zur Verwaltung von diesem Ding.
Ja, aber...
Okay, die Frage, was läuft denn da drauf, was ist die Daseinsberechtigung?
Und was wirkt da drauf?
Aha, okay, okay, jetzt, jetzt, irgendwelche Streaming-Geschichten, okay, irgendwelche Streaming-Geschichten, kann man jetzt schlecht erkennen, was es da eigentlich macht.
Abtime-Kuma ist da drin, hätte ich gedacht, das ist außerhalb, aber okay. Weil es ist immer, also ich, das ist jetzt so eine philosophische Frage, aber ich finde es meistens nicht so sinnvoll, sein Monitoring innerhalb der Systeme laufen zu lassen, die gemonitort werden.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine? Also gerade für ein Monitoring-System wäre es zum Beispiel sinnvoll, das jetzt nicht auf den Hauptrechner mitlaufen zu lassen, sondern auf einem, zum Beispiel auf seinem Raspberry Pi Zero, den er quasi als Backup noch außen stehen hat, das wäre ganz sinnig.
Dann ist nämlich nicht das Monitoring weg, wenn der Service weg ist, den du monitoren willst.
Habt ihr da Krypto, kein Schimmer, was ihr da macht?
Dein Abtime-Kuma läuft auf einem Oracle Tier, ja aber wie kommst du an Internet-Services dran von außen? Hast du da irgendeinen VPN noch am Start oder benutzt du das nur für externe Services? Nee, das wäre mir persönlich nichts, kann man sich aber darüber streiten, ich hätte keinen Bock, dass ich einen VPN aus der Oracle Cloud in mein Internet-Netzwerk aufbauen müsste, dass ich dort irgendwer Monitoring laufen lassen kann.
Ja, schön, schön.
Warum? Weil's geht.
Frank sehe ich genauso, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo der Sinn davon liegt. Ich glaube der Sinn liegt daran, Spaß an der Freud, wie man so in Hessen schön sagt.
Er hat Spaß daran, das zu bauen, er hat Spaß daran, das zu managen und sich damit zu beschäftigen. Das ist ja ein Grund, den lasse ich sogar gelten. Warum nicht, wenn es einem Spaß macht.
Aber man sollte sich glaube ich nicht einreden, dass man damit in irgendeiner Art und Weise wirklich großartig im Heimbereich, ja, ausfallssicherer oder komfortabler oder wie auch immer unterwegs ist.
Man lernt viel, das stimmt. Was zum, was, Moment, hat er noch mal extra Stellen für noch mal Storage? Okay, jetzt steige ich aus, jetzt blinke ich nicht mal durch, was abgeht.
Und morgen habe ich auch noch nie was gehört. Ich weiß nur, dass das mal der Codename für Windows Vista war.
Das heißt, wenn er sein NAS neu starten muss, kacken alle Cluster ab oder wie ist das?
Ja, ach okay, der verwendet Portena gar nichts, der verwendet Portena quasi für die einzelnen Kumpanete oder was oder wie oder hä? Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ja, so ein Setup ist für ihn auch von Vorteil für seine Videos, das stimmt, man kann darüber coole Videos machen. Das ist wohl wirklich so, ja.
Block Pihol bei euch Twitch Werbung, nein, kann es nicht mehr. MonkaS. Okay, was hat er schon? MongoDB, MySQL, NTP, Swingthing, Traffic, ja, okay, es gibt keinerlei Gründe, warum das in einem Kumpanete oder was auch immer Zeug laufen muss.
Ach, das ist jetzt ein Docker-Ondi-Node, Moment. Node von was? Von seinem Kumpanete-Cluster, oder? Ich steige aus, ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Ja, ich meine, wer kennt es nicht? Wer braucht privat nicht auch eine MongoDB MySQL5, MySQL5.6, MySQL5.7? Braucht man immer, da war so alles laufen.
Ja, das ist gut, Traffic habe ich auch. Traffic ist wirklich poggers. Nee, ich nicht. Ich mag Portainer nicht.
Gerade jetzt, wo Docker Compose quasi im Core-Docker dabei ist, finde ich das viel angenehmer. Aber ich bin eh jemand, der gerne Kommandozeile und Textdateien mag. Für jemand, der gerne Webinterface klickt, ist Portainer sicherlich die schönere Variante.
Und es kann auch Kumpanete machen. Also, Reversproxy, das habe ich schon erwähnt. Reversproxy kann kompliziert sein, aber es ist wie ein Proxy, wenn man versteht, was das ist. Also ein Proxy ist viel Traffic zu einem Endpunkt, und es geht alles durch diesen einen Endpunkt. Reversproxy ist, wenn man das etwas nach oben schiebt, nimmt man den ganzen Traffic, der nach unten kommt, an einen Endpunkt. Das ist so, wie ich es verstehe. Aber ein Reversproxy ist etwas, das...
Nee, nicht wirklich. Reversproxy, das stimmt schon, was er erklärt hat, aber die Schlussfolgerung daraus war falsch. Das stimmt schon, was er gesagt hat. Weil im HTTP-Proxy gehen alle Clients zu diesem Proxy hin, der nimmt die Anfragen entgegen und der Proxy schickt das weiter dann an das Ziel, bekommt die Antwort und schickt es dann zurück.
An diejenigen, die angefragt haben. Deswegen heißt es ja auch quasi Stellvertreter. Die eigentlichen Systeme kommunizieren mit dem Proxy und der Proxy kommuniziert mit der Außenwelt.
Beim Reversproxy ist das im Prinzip genau das gleiche. Das verwendest du aber oftmals für so Sachen wie zum Beispiel für automatisches Management von Zertifikaten oder sowas. Sprich, du hast am eingangenen Proxy stehen, darauf greifen die Leute von außen zu und dann leitest du das weiter auf die jeweiligen passenden Systeme.
Also es ist eigentlich genau das gleiche plus umgedreht, aber es hat halt den Vorteil, dass du zum Beispiel Zertifikatsmanagement oder Loadbalancing oder sowas genau an einer zentralen Stelle machen kannst. Also die Funktionsweise ist ziemlich ähnlich, aber der Einsatzzweck ist anders.
Arbeitet jemand mit Excel, VBA, MonkaS? Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Warum? Weil es geht.
All big playtime jetzt.
Was? Ah, nee, das ist eine Traffic-Config, okay. Alter, da wird uns Villas aber echt wissen.
Soll ich euch mal was erzählen, warum ich es aus einem weiterer Grund für nicht so sinnvoll halte? Ich glaube, das muss man aber aus erster Hand erlebt haben, dass man weiß, dass sowas Probleme machen können.
Also Hochverfügbarkeit kann an sich dafür sorgen, dass die Systeme, wenn man es nicht gut macht, weniger verfügbar sind.
Also wie meine ich das? Zum Beispiel dieses Setup, wie er das hat. Sagen wir mal, du hast drei verschiedene Nodes, die sich eine IP teilen. In irgendeiner Art und Weise muss ja diese IP wechseln, wenn der Server down geht. Also die IP liegt ja wirklich nur an einem Node an zur gleichen Zeit.
Und wenn dieser Node down geht, muss irgendjemand anderes die IP übernehmen. Was jetzt ein Problem ist, wenn du es nicht richtig machst. Was passiert? Das muss ich glaube ich aufmalen.
Wir machen jetzt mal. Du hast hier Node 1 und du hast hier keine Ahnung. Du hast hier Node 2. Und die haben eine gescherte IP. Das ist ein Cluster, die haben eine gescherte IP.
So und die IP ist aktuell hier drauf. Ja so funktioniert das. Auf Bildern ist das eigentlich so, dass die IP dann irgendwie da vorne steht und der Traffic angeblich so geht, was aber Schwachsinn ist. Die IP muss ja auf irgendeinem Interface sein. Das funktioniert nicht.
Du kannst doch einen Load Balancer davor machen. Das wäre eine ganz andere Sache. So also das hier ist quasi ein Cluster. Ein Cluster mit einer gescherten IP. Die IP ist immer auf einem aktiv und wenn der kaputt geht, dann switch die IP rüber auf den.
So dann hast du hier vorne hast du irgendwo den Eingang. Machen wir mal hier irgendwie einen Router hin oder so. Das ist jetzt by the way, how to, wie man es nicht richtig macht.
Das da vorne ist eine Fritzbox. Das ist egal. Ist egal was es ist. Wie ist das Cisco Ding für Router? So irgendwie.
So hier hast du deinen Cluster mit der IP. Was passiert jetzt, wenn die Kiste hier abraucht. Also mal angenommen die Kiste hier ist kaputt. Die verreckt. Dann wechselt die IP hier rüber.
So soweit soweit die Idee und in dem Fall bringt dir das auch höhere Verfügbarkeit. Aber jetzt passt mal auf.
Was ist was passiert, wenn die Netzwerkverbindung weggeht? Überlegt mal was passiert, wenn die Netzwerkverbindung weggeht. Doch doch die wechselt doch doch doch die wechselt schon.
Dann passiert folgendes. Dieser Node sieht diesen Node nicht mehr und dieser Node sieht diesen Node nicht mehr.
Das heißt der hier bleibt Master und die IP wechselt auch. Das heißt du hast auf einmal zwei Kisten mit der IP. Beide sind Master.
Das ist an sich jetzt in dieser Konfiguration auch gar nicht so schlimm. Weil naja hier kommt eh nichts rein. Aber sollte der Kram dann wieder funktionieren hast du auf einmal bis die das Ganze wieder geklärt haben auf einmal doppelte IPs.
Deswegen das Mindeste was du machen musst ist sowas hier. Eigentlich brauchst du drei Knoten aber das Mindeste was du machen musst ist eigentlich das hier.
Du brauchst so eine Interconnect Verbindung dazwischen. Das ist das Mindeste was du machen musst. Und eigentlich brauchst du noch einen dritten Node dass das überhaupt funktioniert.
Macht der Router das der Router hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun. Der Router hat keinen Plan von dem was der Router ist auch ein bescheuertes Ding weil ein Router kann das ist dieses Szenario eh nicht.
Das muss das hier hinten muss noch quasi einen Switch. Das ist so eine Fritzbox Router mit Switch dahinter.
Also das ist das Mindeste was du machen musst dass die Nodes sich immer untereinander sehen können. Und komplett korrekt müsstest du es eigentlich machen indem du hier noch einen dritten Node dabei baust.
Oder wenn du richtig pro sein willst baust du keinen dritten Node dabei sondern du baust noch einen dritten Node dabei und du baust quasi offsite irgendwo anders baust du noch ein Quorum oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag.
Der dann im Zweifelsfall entscheidet welcher Master wird. Also man sieht sowas hoch verfügbar zu machen ist nicht einfach damit getan dass man jetzt zwei oder drei verschiedene Cluster Nodes hinstellt.
Und dass diese Sachen hier passieren können ist das was ich meine mit das vermeintliche mehr Hochverfügbarkeit dafür sorgen kann dass es unter dem Strich sogar weniger verfügbar ist wenn es andere anderweitige Probleme gibt.
Also das ist nicht so nach dem Motto man schaltet das eine ist auf einmal alles besser.
Es geht auch mit zwei klar geht das mit zwei aber das Mindeste was du machen musst ist hier dieses Kabel zwischen den Nodes.
Was das bringen soll das soll bringen dass die noch miteinander reden können auch wenn das hier weg ist.
Dass die erkennen können okay der hier wird jetzt Master und der gibt die IP ab.
Weil sobald die nicht mehr miteinander reden können sobald die sich nicht mehr sehen das nennt sich dann entweder es gibt so zwei Sachen so Split Brain oder Split Horizon oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag.
Split Brain finde ich ja persönlich so die beste beste Bezeichnung für das klingt irgendwie so gewalttätig keine Ahnung.
Sobald die sich nicht mehr sehen können in wie auch immer dann sind beide Master weil beide jeweils denken der andere ist weg.
Das ist ein äußerst komplexes Thema und mit einfach wir stellen zwei zwei Nodes hin und es wird viel super besser hoch verfügbar ist es nicht getan.
Damit schaffst du keine Redundanz und keine Ahnung das kommt drauf an was man für Ausfallzeiten definiert.
Also wenn du sagst hey wir dürfen nicht eine TCP Connection verlieren dann wird das in dieser dann wird das so nicht funktionieren aber da gibt es auch Lösungen.
Beispielsweise kann PFSense oder PFSense oder PFSense oder PFSense oder PFSense oder PFSense oder PFSense oder PFSense.
Aber da gibt es auch Lösungen beispielsweise kann PFSense PFSense sage ich jetzt weil es war eines der ersten die das so an fertigen Produkten die das konnten.
PFSense kann den Connection Pool oder wie nennt man das so die quasi die den State der Connection kann PFSense sünken zwischen zwei Nodes.
Das ist dann das ist dann richtig richtig Big Brain Coball in 100 Sekunden also du kannst dann quasi hier deine deine Connection deine Connection States kannst du sünken zwischen zwei Kisten.
Und wenn er die IP wechselt dann bleiben Verbindungen die aufgebaut sind bestehen.
Das ist ziemlich cool das macht natürlich noch ein bisschen komplizierter und anderweitig auch anfälliger.
Ja es ist alles eine Frage was du definiert hast wie lang es rocken darf also das hier geht das geht ja relativ schnell ja.
Sagen wir mal so wenn das wenn das 10 Sekunden dauert dann ist es schon lang je nachdem wie du es wie du es einstellst.
Man darf das aber übrigens auch nicht zu kurz einstellen weil sonst hast du das Problem dass es hin und her wechselt wenn man irgendwie kurzzeitig was ist.
Wie realisiert man den Connect zwischen den beiden Nodes über den Local House das sind zwei unterschiedliche Kisten das sind zwei unterschiedliche Hardware Kisten.
Die haben die haben ein Interconnect Interface und normales Interface oder wenn es eine VM ist stöpselst du die halt virtuell zusammen meinetwegen.
Was der hat ist geht aber schon Richtung Industrie Create deswegen verstehe ich ja den Aufbau auch nicht.
Aber egal machen wir mal weiter.
Ja.
Don't cry so much danke für das Zappen.
Das skippen wir mal wir gucken uns die Sachen an.
Da habe ich selbst noch kein richtig gutes für mich noch keine richtig komplett zufriedenstellende Sache gefunden.
Was Zertifikatsmanagement angeht.
Ich habe ja auch einen Traffic der vor den meisten Services steht und Zertifikatmanagement macht.
Also quasi alles was auf der Hauptkiste läuft mit Docker Compose ist ein Traffic davor.
Und Small Step CA kenne ich habe ich aber noch nie was mitgemacht.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Aber ich habe jetzt beispielsweise auch noch einen Raspberry Pi unten im Keller stehen und Raspberry Pi im Wohnzimmer stehen.
Wo auch jeweils bei dem einen zwei und bei dem anderen ein Service läuft dem ich gerne ein Zertifikat verpassen würde.
Die kann ich theoretisch über mein Traffic laufen lassen dann ist es aber quasi doppelter Traffic der irgendwie verursacht wird.
So muss erst zum Proxy und dann dahin und durchs W-Land doppelt und so.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich bescheuert.
Ich könnte dort lokalen Traffic machen und müsste dort wieder alles hinterlegen was.
Laut Flair Credentials angeht und sowas was cool wäre wenn es eine zentrale.
Also wenn es irgendwie so einen zentralen Let's Encrypt Zertifikatsmanager geben würde habe ich noch nicht gefunden der quasi Zertifikate erneuert.
Und bei jedem Zertifikaten erneuern kann er irgend ein Ding mit Web Interface was für dich die Zertifikate erneuert.
Dann beispielsweise bei jedem erneuern irgendeinen Hook laufen lassen kann der die Zertifikate dort hinschiebt wo sie hinmüssen.
Habe ich noch nichts gefunden in der Richtung ich glaube das wäre echt eine coole Software wenn es sowas gäbe.
Man kann das auch mit Ansible machen.
Dann brauchst du aber trotzdem noch irgendeinen das kannst du ja machen den Hook kannst du ja mit Ansible laufen lassen.
Aber du brauchst irgendwo was was konstant deine Zertifikate refresht.
Also bräuchte es dann quasi auf irgendeiner Kiste müsste dein Zertpot laufen und wenn der Zertpot was neues hat müsstest du dann einen Ansible Run triggern.
Da sind auch wieder ziemlich viele Faktoren dann dabei.
Keine Ahnung mir ist dann auch nichts Gutes zu eingefallen.
Vielleicht habt ihr auf einer von euch Big Brain Idee.
Monitoring Abtai Kuma kommt jetzt.
Ich habe es letztens gesagt wir haben uns das vorletzten Stream angeguckt dieses Tool.
Ich finde es cool.
Das ist für daheim komplett oversized.
Das reicht für 90% der Sachen die du daheim machen willst und es ist viel einfacher und angenehmer zu bedienen.
Engine X Proxy Manager.
Das habe ich glaube ich mal ausprobiert das hat nicht funktioniert wie das was ich mir vorgestellt habe.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr warum.
Keine Ahnung.
Du hast Check MK und Abtai warum hast du zwei?
Also wir haben auf der Arbeit eine Kombination aus Zappix und Prometheus mit Kafana Dashboards.
Weil es gibt halt einfach Sachen die eignen sich wunderbar für Prometheus und manche die eignen sich eher für Zappix.
Ja wenn du so die klassischen Up-Down Monitoring Sachen haben willst dann ist Zappix ganz cool.
Und wenn du irgendwelche eigenen Java Anwendungen hast die Matrix liefern von Connection Pool bis User und Load und sonst was.
Da ist halt die Kombination Prometheus und Kafana ziemlich cool.
Ach so Abteilung für die Status Page das verstehe ich ja das ist cool.
Also ich habe hier ein paar internalen Kubernetes Servers oder Services und einige von denen sind einfach DNS Probes.
Und einige von denen checken HDTV Status Codes um die Website für diese Services zu verabschieden.
Und die Weise in der ich diese alertiere ist ich einfach eine Notifikation zu Discord schicken wenn etwas runter geht.
So ich habe einen privaten Discord Server und schicke diese Notifikationen dort.
Und das ist wie ich weiß ob meine Services hoch oder runter sind.
Du kannst so fancy wie du willst mit Notifikationen. Es unterstützt die Zeit. Aber ich habe Discord gewählt weil es einfach ist und es ist immer auf.
Sprichens von Discord haben wir einen tollen Discord Server. Du sollst total beteiligt sein. Link in der Beschreibung.
Und du kannst sogar eine Status Page kreieren.
Also ich habe hier eine Status Page kreiert die mir einige meiner wichtigen Services zeigen.
Ich werde diese aufbubbeln damit ich sehen kann wie sie sich an den Blick machen.
Es sieht so aus als ob alles gut ist. Oder du kannst es von deinem Dashboard sehen.
Now if you're interested in this I also did a video too. Und I want you to go and have a look.
Du trägst deine 5-6 Kisten ein. Nicht so wie er mit 30 Milliarden Sachen. Du trägst deine 5-6 Kisten ein.
Du kriegst Alerts wenn Zertifikate auslaufen. Du kannst gucken ob deine Kameras noch online sind. Und fertig das reicht.
Du trägst deine 5-6 Kisten ein. Und fertig das reicht.
Es gibt jetzt Checkmk2 seit ein paar Tagen.
Hat jemand schon Checkmk2 ausprobiert? Ist das checkiger als Checkmk1?
Logging
Ja das gibt es auch. Das habe ich ganz verdrängt stimmt. Das gibt es ja auch noch.
Die Sache ist halt die. Ich wüsste gar nicht wofür. Also warum ich meine Logs einsammeln sollte.
Super easy. Berlin convenience.
Also wisst ihr was auch super easy ist? SSH. Less war Syslog. Aber ich glaube das ist nicht im Trend mehr.
Tja. Tja. Das ist halt der Nachteil davon wenn man alles so verkompliziert. Da gehst du nicht einfach per SSH drauf und guckst in deine Logs. Nee.
Während brauchst du natürlich einen extra Log Service. Weil das Zeug keine lokalen Logs im eigentlichen Sinn mehr hat.
Deswegen manchmal ist gerade im Heimbereich weniger mehr.
Ist das ein Daimon oder ein Demon? Da habe ich jetzt schon unterschiedlichste Aussprachen gehört.
Daimon. Okay das wollte ich auch schon mal länger einsetzen bei mir in der Hoffnung ich werde Nexcloud vielleicht los.
Weil ich verwende Nexcloud eigentlich fast nur für File Sync und alles andere an Nexcloud geht mir auf den Sack.
Ja.
Ah. Igitt. Ah. Nexcloud. MonkaS.
Ja dafür ist es auch tatsächlich ganz sinnig. Ich finde Nexcloud hat so ein bisschen die Spur verloren.
Die gehen jetzt voll in diese Enterprise Richtung. Ich bin mal gespannt ob sich das für die auszahlt.
Ja mit ihrem Talk was sie da jetzt eingebaut haben und ihrem Collaboration Office und sowas.
Das ist ja für irgendwelche Enterprise Anwender vielleicht ganz cool.
Aber ich glaube die meisten Enterprise Anwender die verwenden einfach Office 365 und gut ist.
Und für den eigentlichen Anwendungszweck nämlich dass du erstens mal einen robusten File Sync für daheim hast.
Plus vielleicht noch die ein oder anderen Basic Apps von Notizen bis Kalender und Kontakte Sync.
So dass es gut funktioniert und möglichst Features hat die man als Privatnutzer braucht. Ja entfernt sich Nexcloud immer weiter.
Wir hören wollen auf Nexcloud umsteigen. Ganz ehrlich den wünsche ich viel Spaß beim Umstieg auf Nexcloud.
Nexcloud ist so eine Software die ist im Ansatz gut. Die hat auch viele Funktionen die sinnig sind.
Aber es ist so ein bisschen wie Battlefield 2042. Es ist an vielen Stellen einfach nicht fertig oder nicht zu Ende gedacht.
Das merkst du immer wenn du das Node-Taking-Plugin verwendest und stellst dann fest nachdem du es verwendest dass die Suche nicht richtig funktioniert oder sowas.
Das ist alles nicht also ich glaube die beste Beschreibung für Nexcloud ist es ist einfach nicht polished.
Es ist in Ansätzen vorhanden und es ist auch alles eigentlich von den Funktionen ganz sinnvoll.
Aber so ein Polished Gesamtbild und eben auch abgeschlossene in sich funktionierende Plugins hast du halt nicht.
Genau das ist immer ein Schritt weg von gut du denkst hey das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Und dann verwendest du es 1-2 Tage und stellst fest ah Mist die Suche geht nicht richtig.
Ah Mist was weiß ich hier geht das Einbinden nicht richtig.
Ah Mist das Anzeigen von GIFs ich glaube GIFs oder JPEGs gingen eine Weile in der Foto App nicht richtig.
Solche Dinge aber ich würde mal sagen ja.
Und deswegen will ich mein Nexcloud komplett los werden und einfach ich mach wahrscheinlich SYNC-SYNC.
SYNC-SYNC ich brauche ich brauche ich brauche es ja nur für File-SYNC und halt für meine Kontaktliste.
Kontaktliste und Kalender.
Aber da finde ich bestimmt irgendeinen CalDAV Server der das machen kann.
Leider ist das ja auch auf dem absteigenden Ast.
Ja mal gucken.
If you're interested in Nexcloud they have tons of features and they can be used for quite a bit.
But again I just use it for document storage on the web.
Next up is something that's I don't know weird.
Witchamp.
But I categorize it as self promotion or a contact page.
So I created this thing called little link server that's based on the work from an open source product called little link.
And I created a container that allows you to create a website in a docker container just by passing in environment variables.
So you can see this my web server here has my name some links and ways.
Hey das finde ich cool.
This was again inspired by open source.
Das das das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Was verwendet er dafür gibt es irgendwie so ein Profile Page Generator.
Das finde ich echt ganz cool.
Da würde ich dann da würde ich dann Konfig feilen legen sagen hier das das das und das.
Ja man könnte was fertiges nehmen aber das ist ja nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
But I wanted to make it easier for you to self host and put this inside of a container.
And that's totally open source and free to use.
So feel free to go out to my GitHub page and check it out.
Where is your shit hub?
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Zeig mal her.
Nein nein nein nein.
Er baut.
GitHub.
GitHub nicht verlinkt.
Da ist er.
Ach hier.
Little linked server.
Das ist das finde ich tatsächlich ganz witzig.
Warum nicht?
Eigentlich keine schlechte Idee.
Ich mein sowas brauche ich nicht als Docker Container sowas würde ich mir einfach als HTML selbst zusammenbauen.
Aber die finde ich von finde ich von der Idee eigentlich cool.
Ok weiter schlink.
Link short.
So ich habe nicht darüber gesprochen, aber ich habe ihn schon lange benutzt.
Ich habe mir über ein Video gemacht.
Wenn du ein Video von diesem Video sehen willst.
Das Problem an selbst self hosted Link Shortening ist, dass die Leute dem Kram nicht trauen.
Würdet ihr einem Link trauen?
Keine Ahnung.
Blub blub blub.
Punkt wupplos.
Punkt TV oder sowas.
Ich glaube die Leute trauen halt den größeren Short Linker halt vom eher als was selbst gehostet ist.
Schlink ist ein Link Shortener.
Ich glaube sie haben Short Links und haben es zusammengelegt.
Und dann haben sie gesagt das Schlink ist das Name, das eine Waffe macht.
Wenn du es aus der Schicht oder aus der Schicht herrschst.
Aber ich benutze das eigentlich als mein Link Shortener.
Und also warum würde ich einen Link Shortener benutzen?
Ich habe schon ein bisschen bit.ly benutzt.
Und dann habe ich gemerkt, dass bit.ly dich nicht die ursprüngliche URL, die hinter dem Short Link ändert.
Das ist auch gut so.
Damit kannst du ja richtig scammen, wenn du das changen könntest.
Aha, ja kann man machen.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Anwendungsfall, den kann ich irgendwie nachvollziehen.
Das hat einen praktischen, also ich würde es wahrscheinlich nicht aus, aber das hat noch irgendwie einen praktischen Mehrwert.
Aber Schlink ist ein großartiges, selbstführende Option, um das zu machen.
Lass es mich wissen in den Kommentaren und vielleicht werde ich etwas zusammenfassen.
Nächster Punkt ist Home Entertainment.
Also das System, das ich benutze für Home Entertainment ist Plex.
Ich habe vor vielen Jahren eine Lifetime-Subskription von Plex.
Bei einem sehr hohen Preis.
Und seitdem habe ich es schon immer benutzt.
Aber das hat alle meine Regalte TV, Live TV, ein paar meiner Musik.
Und dann ein paar meiner Film-Kollektionen, die ich über Zeit reingesteckt habe.
Und es gibt nicht viel mehr zu sagen über Plex.
Ihr wisst wahrscheinlich, was es ist oder habt es gehört.
Aber dies wiederum läuft innerhalb von einigen der Hardware.
Also während wir über Home-Stuff reden, werde ich über Home-Automation reden.
Ich habe früher Home Assistant benutzt, aber ich musste ein bisschen wechseln,
weil sie keine gute Unterstützung für Google-Device hatten.
Aber jetzt haben sie gute Unterstützung für Google-Device.
Also könnte es Zeit sein, es wieder zu schauen.
In der Zwischenzeit habe ich viele von den Dingen, die Home Assistant gemacht hat, mit zwei Produkten.
Eine ist HomeBridge.
Also HomeBridge ist eine Brücke zwischen Devices, die nicht von HomeKit und HomeKit unterstützt werden.
Ja, ich runne HomeKit bei Home.
Aber ich runne auch Google Home.
Also runne ich zwei Home Assistants mit Unterstützung für alle meine Hardware an beiden Ecosystemen.
Meine Alternative, ich habe keinen Anwendungszweck für Plex.
Ich brauche dazu keine Alternative.
Kind of crazy.
Wenn ich irgendwelche Wots gucken will, dann streame ich die.
Die brauche ich nicht lokal.
Schon Fleet von JetBrains gesehen, ja.
Das ist diese Visual Studio Alternative in Java.
Für alle, die Javascript nicht mögen.
Hey, das ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Ja, die habe ich auch.
Damit kann ich meine Klimaanlage steuern.
Nee, Kodi ist keine Plex-Alternative.
Kodi ist ja nur das Frontend.
Der Plex-Server ist ja das Eigentliche, was Plex ausmacht.
Tonne, danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Ja, also okay, hey, das ist tatsächlich mal was Sinnvolles.
Oh, jetzt kommt die, jetzt kommt USB und Batterie.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie er das macht.
Ich vermute mal, der Nutt-Server und das Nutt-UI,
was wir vorhin im Dashboard gesehen haben, ist das mit der USB.
Sag ich doch, Nutt.
1995 hat angerufen.
Alter, das schaut aus.
Das ist nicht Web 1.1, das ist Web 0.5 oder sowas.
Das hatte ich auch laufen, als ich noch eine USB hatte.
Ich habe ja keine USB mehr.
Meine USB, wo man wieder beim Thema sind,
dass, wenn du es ausfallsicherer machen willst,
die Sache oftmals unausfallsicherer wird.
Mein komplettes Rack war eines Tages aus.
Warum? Weil die USB abgekackt ist.
Komplett Grip.
Nicht, weil der Strom aus war, nein, weil die USB aus war.
Die USB einfach kaputt ist.
Und ich hatte jetzt die Auswahl, mache ich eine neue Batterie rein
und hoffe, dass es wieder funktioniert,
oder lasse ich die USB einfach weg.
Und nachdem ich die letzten 8 Jahre nur einen kompletten Rackausfall hatte,
als die USB kaputt gegangen ist, lasse ich die USB jetzt einfach weg.
Ich habe keinen Netzteil, ich habe keinen Server mit dualen Netzteilen.
Normalerweise sollte das eine USB abkönnen, solange der Strom noch da ist.
Aber in dem Fall anscheinend nicht.
Normalerweise ist es ja kein Problem, wenn die Batterie verreckt.
Weil gerade diese günstigen USBs, die gehen ja nicht konstant durch die Batterie durch.
Die schalten ja quasi nur um auf die Batterie, wenn der Strom ausfällt.
Deswegen sollte die USB eigentlich nicht kaputt gehen.
Oder deswegen sollte das Rack eigentlich nicht ausgehen, wenn der Strom noch da ist.
Und nur die Batterie in der USB kaputt ist.
Aber anscheinend ist das der Fall, was ich ziemlich beschissen finde
und ich im Vorfeld auch nicht wusste.
Ja, bescheuert.
Entweder ich stelle mir eine andere USB rein, wo ich sicher weiß,
die funktioniert auch weiterhin, selbst wenn die Batterie kaputt ist, solange der Strom geht.
Ansonsten brauche ich auch keine USB, weil die Batterie,
da weiß ich, dass die, wenn die so benutzt wird,
dass die definitiv nach 5, 6 Jahren den Geist aufgibt.
Und das muss einfach nicht sein.
So, das ist übrigens auch der hauptsächliche Sinn.
Ich glaube, das geht auch oftmals unter.
Der Sinn von einer USB daheim ist gar nicht mal so sehr,
dass die USB quasi den Stromausfall überbrückt.
Sag mal mal, wenn der Stromausfall jetzt irgendwie wirklich mal 2, 3 Stunden gehen sollte,
dann kannst du nicht erwarten von der USB daheim, dass sie das überbrückt.
Und du hast wahrscheinlich auch keinen Dieselgenerator immer nebenbei im Keller stehen,
der dann einspringt.
Das heißt, der Sinn von der USB ist eigentlich eher der,
das vielleicht kurzzeitig zu überbrücken.
Und wenn das leer geht nach ein paar Minuten oder nach einer Viertelstunde oder was auch immer,
je nachdem, wie viel da dranhängt, dann ist das Wichtige,
dass die Systeme ordentlich runtergefahren werden.
Die Downtime ist ja gar nicht das Problem.
Das Problem ist zum Beispiel, wenn du ein richtig dickes Naster dranhängen hast
mit irgendwie einem großen ZFS-Pool,
das mag das einfach nicht, wenn der Strom komplett instant weg ist.
Gerade große Storage-Pools und ZFS in Kombi, das weiß ich nicht.
Das ist so ein Ding.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so sinnvoll ist, wenn einfach der Strom weg ist.
Ich würde mir dann eher Gedanken machen um die Konsistenz meiner Storage-Pools
als an die Downtime.
WordPress? bonkers.
Da fang ich ja schon an zu schwitzen, wenn ich das seh.
Hab ich euch mal die Story erzählt auf der Arbeit, wo unser WordPress,
was wir irgendwo extern gehostet hatten,
bei irgendeinem externen Provider gehackt wurde
und dann benutzt wurde, um weitere Wordpress-Instanzen von uns anzugreifen.
Und jetzt kommt die Super Business Enterprise Story drumherum.
Das Team, was dafür zuständig war, hat gesagt, wir können das WordPress nicht abschalten,
weil es lief gerade irgendwo eine Ausstellung oder so.
Also irgendwo lief eine Ausstellung und die WordPress-Seite war für die Ausstellung.
Die haben gesagt, wenn wir das WordPress jetzt abschalten,
dann ist die Ausstellungsseite nicht verfügbar.
Da haben wir gesagt, ja, das Ding ist gehyjacked
und es versucht, andere WordPress von uns anzugreifen mit Skriptgedöns.
Wir müssen das jetzt ausschalten und das Team meinte,
nein, wir können das nicht ausschalten.
Die Ausstellung braucht diese Webseite.
Und da haben wir dann damals gesagt, so nach dem Motto
Ja, gut, dann sagt uns halt, sagt uns eine sinnvolle Alternative
oder wir ziehen den Stecker.
Genau, Captain Peng, genau so haben wir das gemacht.
Also nennet uns einen Ansprechpartner,
nennet uns hier Alternativen, wie auch immer wir das machen sollen.
Überlegt euch was, ansonsten ziehen wir den Stecker.
Und es hat einen Tag gedauert, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Corporate Enterprise Geschwindigkeit, es hat einen Tag gedauert
und morgens um acht habe ich es runtergefahren, die Kiste, habe ich ausgeschaltet.
Und es hat eine halbe Stunde gedauert,
dann standen die Leute unten und haben gesagt, ja, wie machen wir das denn jetzt?
Da habe ich mir auch noch gesagt, ja, gestern ganzen Tag euch das zu überlegen.
Ich mache da gar nichts, ich lasse das jetzt aus.
Ich kann euch eine neue Kiste hinstellen, ihr könnt neues WordPress installieren
oder was auch immer.
Ja, aber wir müssen die Daten doch abziehen von dem alten WordPress.
Wir haben die Seite doch auf dem neuen da nicht.
Und das Ganze ging sogar, ging sogar so weit, dass sogar unsere Sicherheit,
also unsere alte Sicherheit war sogar auch dabei und sogar das,
da hat es einen Tag danach gedauert.
Das ist wirklich echt grenzwertig.
Da sieht man mal, wie schwerfällig und langsam so so größere Läden sind.
Kein Wunder, dass da, dass da alles immer drei Jahre dauert.
Ja, okay, WordPress müssen wir uns jetzt nicht anhören.
Static Sage, eine Dynamic DNS, okay, wie macht er sein DNS?
Hugo, ja, Cloudflare verwende ich auch für DNS und Zertifikate.
Ach nee, das macht er für vom Außen auf seine dynamische IP zuzugreifen, okay.
Ja gut, brauche ich nicht, es juckt mich nicht.
Oh, jetzt, jetzt wird es DevOps Agile, Leute, Massive Agilität.
Flixi Hype, Dein Schiff in den Zap.
Ah, yes.
Da muss ich halt sagen, ich habe kein Interesse, das lokal laufen zu lassen.
Es gibt Sachen dort, wo ich meine Daten ablege und sowas.
Ja, wunderbar, das kann alles lokal laufen und das sollte alles lokal laufen.
Aber mit GitHub Actions bin ich wirklich zufrieden in letzter Zeit.
Also ich mag GitHub Actions und ich wüsste nicht, warum ich das lokal laufen lassen sollte.
Schön, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden hast, Halb.
Shit, Shit-Server.
Ja, okay, müssen wir uns das nicht angucken, all the things, okay.
Wichtig, RGB-Steuerung ist das Allerwichtigste und Wort CS, Dankeschön für den Zap.
Okay, wir haben alles gesehen, ich glaube, da kommt nicht mehr so viel.
Ja, also Fazit muss ich sagen, es ist extrem oversized für daheim.
Ich halte es nicht sinnvoll, aber in seinem Fall kann es natürlich sinnvoll sein, stecke
ich ja nicht drinnen und es ist bestimmt auch viel Spaß an der Freude dabei, einfach
das zu lernen und zu managen und aufzubauen.
Ich denke mal, dass bei ihm ist da auch viel Spaß dran, dass er einfach an der Verwaltung
von dem Zeug Spaß hat.
Ob es so viel bringt, ich weiß nicht, weil ganz im Ernst, was für ein Vorteil ist das,
was er da aufgebaut hat im Heimbereich versus irgendwie so einer simplen Lösung aus irgendwie
einem Low-Power-X86-Kiste, 14TB Festplatte dran, eine zweite 14TB Festplatte per USB
dran, einmal nachts den Sync machen, eventuell noch Offside-Backup machen und vielleicht
noch 2-3 Raspberry Piles im Haus verteilt haben, dort wo man sie braucht, mit der passenden
Software drauf, fertig.
Du hast auch keinen wirklichen riesen Single Point of Failure mehr, klar, wenn eins kaputt
geht ist ein Service weg, aber nicht alles und es ist natürlich theoretisch nicht so
ausfallssicher wie sein Setup, aber es ist viel, viel einfacher und simpler und allein
schon deswegen glaube ich, dass man weniger Probleme mit hat.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch schönes zu bieten?
Apps fürs Handy, so viel verdient ein angestellter App-Designer.
Ich muss jetzt mal einen YouTube Comment imitieren, wie hipster willst du aussehen?
Antwort, ja, er sieht schon so typisch agiler moderner Startup App-Programmierer aus, was
nicht über seine Fähigkeiten aussagt, by the way, wer will ich da drüber zuurteilen,
aber ich finde das Setup sieht schon äußerst hipster aus, so mit dem Hemd und dem Bart und
dem Cabbie auf, so richtig Startup-Hipster.
Okay, zeig mal her, also wie viel verdient ein App-Designer?
Lohnt sich das?
Ich glaube die Gesellschaft sollte viel öfter mit Geld umgehen.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Da ist der Auto und das fetteste Pferd, ja, da gebe ich ihm komplett recht, diese Sache
mit über Geld spricht man nicht, finde ich blöd, weil es im Endeffekt eigentlich nur
der anderen Seite in die Hände spielt, weil was hat man dafür, auf der Arbeit unter Kollegen
nicht über Geld zu reden, nichts, das im Zweifelsfall der Arbeitgeber mit weniger Geld bezahlen
durchkommt, also ansonsten hat es eigentlich gar keinen Sinn.
Fernseher, aber über Gehalt und Geld redet dann irgendwie doch keiner und das finde ich
sehr schade.
Ich glaube, ich würde meinen Job auch machen, ohne Geld dafür zu bekommen, einfach weil
es mir verdammt...
Ackermans, was macht er da, Zack, muss ich mal kurz gucken?
Also was haben wir denn da, C.content, ist das Flutter, nee, nee, was ist das?
TSX, ach nee, das ist React, das ist React, oder was meint ihr, wer kennt sich damit aus,
ist das React?
Ich vermute mal, das ist React, TypeScript React, oh, React Native, oh, krasser Bass,
ja, das någonting他有 investigating, aber ich glaube so nennt man das auch.
Wir sind in vier verschiedene Teams aufgesplittet.
Eines davon ist das Banking Team, in dem ich arbeite.
Wir kümmern uns darum, das bestmögliche mobile Banking hinzubekommen.
Halli, hallo.
Hi, Halli.
Wir haben ein neues Feature, das wir...
Okay, der Arbeitsplatz, der würde bei mir definitiv nicht so clean aussehen.
Mein Arbeitsplatz sieht ein bisschen aus wie mein Desktop.
Nicht ganz so schlimm.
Außerdem, ja, außerdem ein bisschen wenig Monitor.
Aber hey, jeder, wie er das gerne macht.
Ich meine, es gibt auch Leute, die mit dem Trackpad und der Notebook-Tastatur arbeiten.
Er ja anscheinend auch.
Mir ist nicht klar, wie man mit dem Notebook und dem Trackpad arbeiten kann den ganzen Tag,
aber es gibt genug Leute anscheinend.
Das heißt, Kunden können mit jeder Kartenzahlung einen Betrag aufrunden
und den in ein nachhaltiges Projekt stecken.
Ah, deswegen ist das nachhaltig.
Jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Das ist ein bisschen wie Trinkgeld bezahlen bei Lieferando.
Du weißt auch nicht, wo es hingeht.
Üben, packen.
Und dann haben wir heute Nachmittag noch ein kleines User-Testing mit ein paar Leuten,
wo wir das validieren wollen, ob das so funktioniert, wie wir uns das überlegt haben.
Also wir haben noch 5 Stunden abzüglich Mittagspause.
Das wird spannend.
Hacker-Man, auf geht's.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man Apps mit Zettel programmiert, aber gut, kann man machen.
User-Stories.
Im visuellen Design ist es so, dass wir uns sehr oft inspirieren lassen von anderen Apps
und anderen Branchen, wie die das machen, aber auch natürlich, wie wir schon unsere
eigene App gerade haben und die natürlich auch ähnlich aussehen sollte.
Wisst ihr, was schon mal cool ist? Das ist realistischer als die anderen Videos.
Der sitzt am Rechner und arbeitet einfach und macht nicht irgendwelche komischen, vom
Daily bis zum Sonstwas, bis zu Programmierungs-Dojos und Sonstwas, nein, der arbeitet einfach.
Mal kurz die Welt aufzumachen und sich anzugucken, wie machen das die anderen da draußen in
dieser Welt, um nicht immer nur auf Samplanken zu stehen.
Gut geklaut ist halb, nee, ich weiß gar nicht, wie heißt das?
Gut geklaut ist halb gewonnen, nee, gut abgeguckt ist, keine Ahnung, ja, sehe ich aber auch
so, man muss es ratlich neu erfinden.
Ich habe mein Abi in Bayern gemacht, habe währenddessen ein bisschen gefreelancet für
verschiedene Agenturen damals, dachte mir, jetzt lerne ich das richtig, habe mich für
ein Praktikum in Hamburg beworben, bin dann nach Hamburg gezogen.
Besser gut geklaut als schlecht erfunden, ja.
Und wurde nach dem Praktikum einfach übernommen und habe dann so mein Unwesen, das ist so
und habe dann so mein Unwesen in verschiedenen Agenturen getrieben und bis jetzt hat noch
niemand rausgefunden, dass ich da vielleicht auch gar keine Ausbildung für habe.
Macht ja nichts, ist doch scheißegal, wenn er das kann, ich glaube, das ist das Unerhebliche
überhaupt, wenn er das kann, was da von ihm verlangt wird, ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich habe mir Gedanken gemacht, wo man dieses Feature denn aktivieren könnte, das kann
man auf dem Profil, in den Karteneinstellungen, auf der Buchungsteilseite, ich glaube das
sinnvollste ist auf dem Impact Board, das wir haben.
In meinem Vertrag stehen 40 Stunden.
Das ist jetzt aber auch ein bisschen gestellt für das Video, oder?
Also, ich weiß nicht, mit Post jetzt auf dem, so, so, so, so, okay, jener hat andere Ansätze,
aber keine Ahnung, also, was das, was das, das ist glaube ich eher zur Visualisierung
für die Zuschauer, naja, gut, jeder wie er gut arbeiten kann, ne?
Das ist sehr abhängig von der Woche.
Also, manchmal ist es stressiger, würde ich behaupten, macht man mal 50, 60 Stunden die
Woche, manchmal ist es ein bisschen entspannter, aber man weiß am Ende immer, warum man sich
dahinter hängt.
Weiß man das?
Und es ist niemand von außen einfach sagt, du musst jetzt arbeiten, sondern man hat Bock,
das jetzt irgendwie zu Ende zu machen, oder man möchte jetzt irgendwie was voranbringen
und dadurch kommen meistens die Überstunden, wenn dann.
Was ist das?
Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, was das für eine Software ist?
Wer kennt sich mit, wer kennt sich mit sowas, das ist irgendwie so, ach, Figma ist das,
Figma hat eh die beste, beste, äh, äh, Ausprache auf Deutsch, Figma, Alter, das ist dobb,
das ist ein Verscheuer, es gibt manche Software, die hört sich auf Deutsch ausgesprochen
dumm an.
Figma, stimmt, ja, ja, hab ich noch nie richtig benutzt, aber ich kenn das.
Oligma, nicht Figma, ja, was ist es denn jetzt?
Das tool nutzen wir ganz viel, um Sachen zu scribbeln, also erst mal so anzumalen,
um zu gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Ah, er hat doch jetzt gesagt sogar, was es ist, oder?
Das tool nutzen wir ganz viel, um Sachen zu scribbeln, also erst mal so anzumalen, um
zu gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Ja.
Ich hab jetzt hier gerade so 5, 6, 7 Varianten davon gebaut, wie ich mir das vorstellen
könnte.
Die sind alle ganz grob, ange-, des-, undesigned.
Okay, er ist wirklich App-Designer, ich weiß gar nicht, ob er, vielleicht meinen die das
wirklich ernst, er ist gar kein Entwickler, er ist App-Designer, weil in der Regel ist
es so, sag mal mal, dass jetzt vielleicht Designer nicht unbedingt zwangsläufig die
besten Entwickler sind, Entwickler nicht zwangsläufig die besten Designer, also, gutes Ergebnis
kommt da, oder ich, ich, also ich denke, das bessere Ergebnis kommt raus, wenn die zwei
Welten zusammenarbeiten, ja, mag sicherlich den einen oder anderen geben, der beides gut
kann, also so könnte ich nicht arbeiten, das funktioniert nicht.
Ich bräuchte erstens mal den großen Monitor, allein schon, dass ich checken kann, wie sieht
es auf dem Desktop aus, wie sieht es mobile aus und sonst wie was, äh, und vor allem,
ich bräuchte eine Tastatur und eine Maus, vielleicht ist es einfach, weil es cool aussieht.
So, jetzt wird erstmal was gefuddert, wisst ihr was geil, die, die sehen alle so krass
hipster aus, man, mit der Hand, oder man gewöhnt sich daran, dass man viel Geld dafür, oder
mehr Geld dafür ausgibt, jeden Mittagessen zu gehen, aber es ist auch immer sehr lecker,
dafür essen wir abends meistens nicht so viel.
Denn ist Homeoffice Pock, du gibst weniger Geld aus und du bist noch daheim und kannst
in Ruhe futtern, anstatt wenn irgendwo in Frankfurt in irgendeinem Restaurant beim Mittagessen
Krach rumsitzt.
Es ist bestimmt vegan, also mindestens, nein, huge joke, huge joke, ähm, das ist bestimmt
vegan, Leute, ich werde mit euch, veganer Käse, veganer Nudeln, alles vegan.
Also, was wir hier haben, ist einmal, äh, ganz oben, was unser Fortschritt ist, also
wie wir wahrscheinlich erreicht haben, einmal einen Aufruf mitzumachen, dabei eine ganz
kurze Erklärung, um was es dabei geht, wenn man da drauf tippen würde, würde es sich
nochmal ein Overlay auftun, dann würden wir das nochmal größer erklären, und unten
direkt unser Call to Action, ähm, dass der Nutzer oder die Nutzerin dieses Feature direkt
anmachen kann.
Also mit einem Klick ist dieses Feature angemacht, ich sehe, ähm, was es dir geht, das muss
du tatsächlich so machen, das ist das, glaube ich, auch was viele, halt, eingesetzt unter
anderem da, wo ich, wo ich auch arbeite, was sie nicht verstehen, ist, du musst damit
rechnen, dass die User eigentlich nichts, also erstens, nichts checken, so wirklich,
und auch kein Bock haben, deine Software wirklich zu benutzen, also User heutzutage haben ja
keine Spaß dran, also nein, was soll ich sagen, User benutzen nicht eine Software, weil sie
die Software benutzen, User benutzen heute die Software, weil sie was machen wollen,
und umso simpler und direkter du das machen kannst, umso besser, und wenn irgendeine Konkurrenz
um die Ecke kommt, und du nicht irgendwie so ein super, sagen wir so, Alleinstellungsmerkmal
hat, die das einfach mit drei Klicks weniger erledigen kann, dann nehmen die das, die sind
da überhaupt nicht mehr investiert, die nehmen einfach das, was am besten für den Task funktioniert.
Deswegen, das musste, kommst du heute nicht drumherum, das muss so simpel sein, wie irgendwie
möglich.
Du wolltest doch mal Informationen mit reinbringen, wie viele deiner Kontakte oder Freunde auch
schon dabei sind, und das Design würde ich ganz gerne mal in den Prototypen bringen und
gucken, wie sich das anfühlt, wenn man es wirklich antippt.
Deine Freunde sind auch dabei, das heißt, die App fragt dich beim Aufmachen, wollen
sie ihr Kontakt, ihr Adressbuch scheren, das erste, was ich machen würde, ist mal, nein,
ich möchte nicht mein Adressbuch scheren.
Kann, ob das noch cool ist oder doch eher nicht.
Hallo, ich bin Uwe, ich bin auch dabei.
Es ist relativ viel Gefühl, muss ich zugeben.
Choose my name, Dankeschön.
Weil es da auch viel um Ästhetik geht.
Du hast zwölf Monate und hast jetzt den Goldkeks.
Ich weiß nicht, ich baue Dinge und habe dann das Gefühl, es funktioniert gut oder es sieht
gut aus, aber es funktioniert ja nicht so gut.
So ein paar Sachen kennt man.
Das macht den mir sympathisch, weil ich glaube, ich habe noch nie von irgendeinem Designer
eine schlüssige Erklärung gehört, ab wann was gut aussieht und ab wann was nicht.
Da gibt es bestimmt irgendwelche super krassen Erklärungen dafür, so nach dem Motto, 20%
hier, 30% hier, aber ich glaube, die ehrlichste Antwort ist, ich habe ein gutes Bauchgefühl,
dass es gut aussieht und wenn man da noch ein gutes Gefühl dafür hat, was die Kunden
gerne hätten, was ja einigen auch komplett abgeht, dann fährt man damit ganz gut.
Der goldene Schnitt, alles klar.
Einfach oder die weiß man, dass man nicht sagt, besser funktionieren, man nicht sagt,
schlechter funktionieren, aber so das Ästhetische ist eigentlich immer viel zu...
Na ja, mit seinen Posts jetzt ja.
Ich finde, das beste, was man haben kann, ist, dass man sich keine Gedanken machen
muss um das Geld.
Also wenn ich Lust habe, heute Abend essen zu gehen, dass ich es einfach machen kann.
Ohne Scheiß sehe ich genauso.
Mehr brauchst du nicht.
Wenn ich übers Wochenende in Udaw fahren möchte, dass ich es einfach ohne darüber nachzudenken
machen kann.
Solange du nicht laufend jeden Cent umdrehen musst, ist doch eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Auf alle Fälle komme ich damit super klar.
Man muss sich dran erinnern, dass es ein krasses Privileg ist, dass man wahrscheinlich hat,
das nicht selbstverständlich ist.
Na ja, man muss es relativ sehen, wenn der teilweise 50-60 Stunden Wochen arbeitet, also
dann relativiert sich das wieder ein bisschen mit, das ist so viel.
Und Hamburg, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung, wie es in Hamburg so ist.
Bekommt er die Überstunden bezahlt?
Ja, bestimmt.
Ansonsten wäre das fragwürdig.
Schauen, ob sie das verstehen, wo sie hängen, warum sie was nicht verstehen, warum sie
was gut finden und es ist eher die Frage, warum und was den Nutzer antreibt.
Hallo Pauline.
Hallo.
Ganz vorab, du kannst alles, was wir sagen, du kannst nichts falsch machen, wenn du das
nicht verstehst, du bist nicht die schuldige Person, dann sind wir das, die das gemacht
haben.
Wie?
Die testen ihre Software?
Was ist das für Hexenwerk?
Also wenn ich mir Battlefield 2042 angucke, dann sieht man auch ganz klar, man kann Sachen
releasen, ohne das einmal getestet zu haben.
Wir haben einen kleinen Prototypen für dich vorbereitet.
Die testen einfach ihre Sache.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist ein Abbild der Tomorrow App.
Bei EA wäre das nicht passiert.
Kannst du mir mal zeigen, wo das sein könnte?
Wieso suchst du da?
Weil es die Settings sind?
Also eigentlich will ich ja Geld senden, oder?
Wieso glaubst du, es ist bei Geld senden?
Also das wäre natürlich jetzt nur, wenn ich, also naja stimmt, wenn ich jetzt quasi direkt
mit der Karte bezahle, muss ich ja da irgendwie aufrunden können.
Das wäre jetzt so mein erster Tipp für mich.
Ja, ja.
Klingt logisch, klingt nachvollziehbar, ja.
Was, indem du Kartenzahlungen aufrundest, unterstützt du den Bau von mobilen Solaranlagen
in Uganda?
Aha.
Ach deswegen ist das nachhaltig.
Ich gebe dir einen kleinen Hint, guck doch mal auf dem Impact-Board nach, ob das da
sein könnte.
Ja, hier steht es ja eigentlich, ne?
Impact.
Okay, kein normaler User hat doch irgendwie einen Plan, was ein Impact-Board ist, oder?
Ich wüsste nur ich mal, wann ich in das Impact-Board überhaupt gucke.
Achso, Impact, ah doch, okay, doch, doch hätte ich, wenn ich eine nachhaltige App verwende
zum Banken und es halt aus diesem Grund mache, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich auch in das
Impact-Board gucken, weil dann sehe ich, was es nachhaltig bringt, dass ich diese App
verwende.
Hab ich gesehen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin ja draußen, ne?
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Cool, das war tatsächlich auch schon so der Hauptteil, den wir ein bisschen herausfinden
wollten.
Danke, Scheer.
Tschüss.
C U.
Ja, sehr spannend, also so, ich dachte, es ist super aufmerksam.
Weil was machen die da mit ihren Post-its?
Ich mein, jeder hat seine andere Art zu arbeiten, warum nicht?
Ich glaube, ich würde Anfälle kriegen, wenn ich den ganzen Tag irgendwelche Post-its kleben
würde, aber jeder war es funktioniert, ja?
Aber immerhin, wisst ihr, was in dem Video cool ist?
Der arbeitet tatsächlich nicht so wie die anderen Typen, die letzten Videos über, die
den Hälfte, den 80% des Tages sonst was gemacht haben.
Die hat ja sehr lange gebraucht, um das zu finden.
Die Frage ist, ob die Posts jetzt nachhaltig sind, ja.
Test Nummer 2.
Aber guck mal, der arbeitet wenigstens den ganzen Tag.
Also, ich würde jetzt gerne ein Video machen, durch den ich gerne durchführen würde, und
jetzt würde ich dich bitten, mir einmal zu zeigen, wo du das an- und ausschalten kannst.
Und denk dabei gerne laut, also was dir durch den Kopf kommt, wenn du denkst, oh mein Gott,
wo bin ich?
Okay, genau, also ich hab's, wenn ich aktiv bei Instagram gesehen, ich würde schätzen,
wenn ich Geld sende.
Wissen Sie?
Warum suchst du es denn bei Geld senden?
Das war jetzt so das Erste.
Ich dachte, das ist so, wie wenn du bei der Supermarktkasse bezahlst, dann ist ja quasi
... Kannst du aufrunden, ja.
Natürlich ist das ein bisschen gestellt für das Video, aber immerhin, es gibt einen sinnigen
Einblick in den Tagesablauf, und der arbeitet wenigstens auch, nicht wie die anderen in
den Videos.
Der Typ im letzten Video, der hat, glaub ich, den ganzen Tag nicht gearbeitet, nur abends
im Wald irgendwelche Baumstämme verrückt.
Dann würde ich das jetzt, glaub ich, in meine Einstellung suchen.
Da ist es.
Nee, also dann... Er hat's nicht gesehen.
... wüsste ich jetzt grad auch gar nicht, wo ich suchen soll.
Keiner klickt auf das Impact-Board, ja.
Dann würde ich es jetzt hier wippen.
Dann vielen Dank für deine Zeit, und ich wünsche dir noch einen schönen Nachmittag.
Jo.
Hey, was haben wir gelernt?
Es ist ja viel tatsächlich.
Also so ein paar Sachen, die wir eigentlich gar nicht wissen wollten, haben wir gelernt.
Ansonsten haben wir gelernt, dass irgendwie alle Leute das bei Geld senden suchen.
Wobei ich eigentlich dachte, das wäre super-obvies, dass es ein Impact-Board ist, aber scheinbar
ist es nicht so.
Dann werden wir morgen wahrscheinlich noch mal eine neue Runde drehen und uns überlegen,
ob das immer so ist.
Es war nicht so obvies wie gedacht.
Oder ob man das anpasst.
Also ja, manchmal setzt man da und denkt, man hätte übermäßig schlaue Gedanken da reingesteckt
und es wäre das genialste Feature der Welt, und dann stellt man fest, niemand versteht
es.
Es ist immer traurig, aber dann muss man irgendwie leben.
17.30 Uhr.
Da bin ich schon zwei Stunden mich um YouTube kümmern.
15.30 Uhr ist Schluss bei mir.
Sowohl Homeoffice, na gut, Homeoffice bin ich manchmal noch bis 16 Uhr da, 15.30 Uhr
fahre ich auf der Arbeit heim, oder 15.30, 16 Uhr mache ich Homeoffice Schluss.
Dafür fange ich aber auch schon relativ früh an.
Ja, ja gut, er fängt wahrscheinlich später an.
Ich weiß nicht, wann fängt er an?
War das am Anfang irgendwie Zack?
Warte mal, wir sind bei 10.24 Uhr, ich will mal kurz gucken, wann er angefangen hat.
Wie viel Uhr fängt er an?
9 Uhr.
Ah ja, ja gut, dann ist kein Wunder, dass 17.30 ist, der hat was gefuttert und dann
acht Stunden.
Ja.
Aber neun wäre mir viel zu spät.
Ich war sonst immer 6.45 Uhr da, so.
Wir zahlen gerade 1300 Euro netto für die Wohnung, was recht günstig ist für die Wohnlage
und das teilen wir 50-50 gerade zwischen mir und meiner Freundin auf.
Ich finde Putzen furchtbar anstrengend und immer wenn ich das machen muss, da bist du
immer so lange vor mir hergeschoben, bis du kann noch seine Freundin putzen lässt.
Das darf man nicht laut sagen, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Dass es eigentlich schon zu spät war und deswegen habe ich immer entschieden, dass
ich vielleicht mal eine Anzeige ist, die schwerer.
Anzeige ist raus.
Wirklich immer.
Wir haben einmal zusammen gekocht bei unserem dritten Date und dann glaube ich nie wieder.
Also.
Sitzen zu arbeiten, an einem Rechner, dann nach Hause zu kommen und das Einzige, was
man macht, so wie das eine Fenster zu und das andere auf und dann macht man irgendwie
was ganz anderes, wie dein Bildschirm und da ist mir schon wichtig, da irgendwie einen
Ausgleich am Abend zu haben.
Ja und hier mache ich das eigentlich super gerne Musik, also ich komme eigentlich aus
der Klavierecke und habe irgendwann angefangen mit elektronischem Kram weiterzumachen und
das finde ich irgendwie sehr witzig, dass beides.
Wie?
Einer, der abends nicht vor dem Computer hängt, was denn da los?
Verbinden.
Gut, er ist ja auch Designer und kein Entwickler.
Und damit Musik zu machen.
Also da kann ich eben die Stunden verbringen, hier, die, ok, naja, aber immerhin, ich muss
echt sagen, das war ein gutes Video, man hat erkennt, er arbeitet tatsächlich im Vergleich
zu den anderen.
Wie schaffen die das, so wenig zu essen auszugeben?
Ja es kann halt nicht jeder so viel futtern, wie wir.
Hast du das mal gesehen?
Ja, das kenne ich, das ist aber auch schon 10 Jahre alt oder so.
Einfach nichts essen, forehead.
Oh, nee, ich glaube mit so einem kontroversen Thema machen wir es nicht weiter.
Perfect Home Server Build hätten wir noch zu bieten.
Revue Battlefield muss nicht sein, tyrannischen Mods, Stag Overflow, Only Battlefield Moments,
Smart, den gucke ich immer gerne, der hat total, der übertreibt es bei sich daheim immer
richtig.
Das kaputte Image von Actiun, wie es kaum 100 Sekunden, Moment, Sekunde Leute, ich hatte
noch auf dem Handy etwas, was ich mir extra gespeichert habe, dass wir uns das angucken
können.
Moment, Moment, das gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an.
Developer Trends 2022, Watch Later.
Developer Trends 2022, das, das da wollte ich mir angucken mit euch, genau, dass wir mal
wissen, auf was wir aufpassen müssen in 2022, ob wir alle Cobol lernen müssen.
Cobol in 100 Sekunden, das haben wir uns doch sogar schon mal angeguckt.
Hard to make predictions, especially about the future.
But that's exactly what we'll try to do in this video.
2021 was a strange year.
There was a big regime change, we finally beat the pandemic and everybody took off their
masks and went back to the office.
That was the original plan anyway.
Unfortunately, it's your conspiracy theorist uncle on Facebook who keeps making the right
predictions.
But as developers and entrepreneurs, we don't care about these externalities.
We figure out ways to make money writing code with the environment they give us.
We thrive in the chaos.
If you're new here, like and subscribe, then we'll start things off by looking at major
trends that will influence the developer landscape in 2022.
Also, was müssen wir lernen für 2022?
Ich, ich predikte, ich predikte mal was.
Mehr JavaScript frameworks.
Weird app ideas that you can use to build a quadrillion dollar startup.
The first trend we need to talk about is Web 3 or the decentralized Web.
2.0 is out, 3.0 kommt jetzt, okay.
Web 3.
Some people think Web 3 is the point where all modern technology converges, out of which
new unimaginable technologies will diverge in the future.
Other people though think that Web 3 is just the latest buzzword to pump crypto scams.
But what is Web 3 exactly?
A completely decentralized version of our current internet, with no firewalls, no tolls, no
government regulation.
You want to build a new internet.
It's basically a vision for the internet, where everything is decentralized and regulated
with smart contracts and crypto, instead of the current status quo, where everything is
controlled by Google, Facebook and Amazon.
In a decentralized app or dApp, the user owns all their data.
Die Sache ist nur die.
Das ist alles von der Idee her ehrenwert, die Sache ist bloß die, solange das nicht
einen Mehrwert oder zumindest einen einfachen Einstieg für den 0815 Casual Noob Benutzer
bietet, wird das zumindest breitflächig kein Erfolg sein, was es aber auch nicht zwangsläufig
sein muss.
Je nachdem, was es dann da halt gibt und für wen das ansprechend ist, weil man darf nicht
vergessen, das Internet, was weiß ich 1995, war auch alles andere als einsteigerfreundlich.
Es hat trotzdem was gebracht.
Instead of an email password identity, users are identified by a blockchain wallet address
that usually connects with a browser plugin like MetaMask, while the app itself is code
that lives on the blockchain in the form of a smart contract.
The idea is really cool, because it gives people more control over their own slice of the
Internet, as opposed to using services that are mediated by a central ivory tower like
a big tech corporation or government.
On the other hand, there are a ton of ways one might criticize Web3.
It's chaotic, hard to develop quality apps with current tool chains.
It doesn't benefit most mainstream businesses in any practical way.
Most of the tokens are owned by Silicon Valley insiders, so it's not really decentralized
at all.
And you really don't need cryptocurrency to build a decentralized app in the first place.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch was?
Web3.0, alles klar, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt,
alles klar, jetzt, jetzt weiß ich Bescheid.
Das stimmt wohl.
To limit our ability to point out bad content.
What I think would be awesome is an entirely decentralized news network, where journalists
could upload video, articles and other reporting and be compensated based on its reach.
It would incentivize good journalism and eliminate the possibility of a top-down propaganda machine.
Journalists win, consumers win, the only one who gets f**ked is the establishment.
And now a word from our sponsors.
Hi, my name's Jeff and I'm a 10x developer and you can be one too if you start every
day with a hearty...
Das ist doch wieder Fake Commercial, oder?
Breakfast from McDonald's, like the Sausage Egg McMuffin Value Meal.
Available for a limited time for under 14 dollars.
Remember guys, real developers eat at McDonald's.
I'm loving it.
Da da da da daaa.
I'm finished.
And that brings us to our next trend, the metaverse.
You likely saw Mark Zuckerberg's...
Oh ja, das hab ich mitbekommen und ich hab nicht verstanden, was er eigentlich von mir will.
...envision about the metaverse.
Hat das irgendjemand gecheckt, was er eigentlich von einem will?
Außer noch mehr unsere Daten.
3 of that, because I would never want to be involved in any kind of metaverse run by
Apps within that platform and communicate with other users in a virtual environment like you would in VR chat or an old school
App. The concept is actually really cool, but
Kann sich da noch jemand dran erinnern, wo alle auf diesen, ich hab das, by the way, ich hab es nie installiert gehabt, ich hab mich auch nie eingeloggt gehabt, ich fand das schon immer total hängen geblieben, aber kann sich noch jemand dran erinnern, wo damals alle größeren Firmen mitbekommen haben, so fast Second Life, wir brauchen da auch was, wo die dann richtig viel Geld reingebuttert haben,
dass dann keine Ahnung, Mercedes irgendwie ein Second Life Filiale hatte und da sind dann nur zwei Leute reingegangen, die es hier besucht haben und ein Jahr später war das Spiel komplett dead.
Roblox.
Roblox ist doch auch im Prinzip mittlerweile nur noch ein Marketplace, um Spielekopien in Roblox zu verkaufen, oder? Da gibt es so viele Ripoffs, ich meine, es gibt ja sogar von Among Us bis, ach, keine Ahnung, es gibt alles Mögliche.
Da gibt es bestimmt sogar Mario Kart und sowas, also den Sinn von Roblox verstehe ich auch nicht.
Was hat er da eigentlich für Videopodage im Hintergrund? Was sind das für komische Apparate, die sie da am Start haben? Sind das irgendwelche VR-Gestelle, wo du dann auch drin rennen kannst und sowas?
Ich sehe nur, dass die Demo, guckt euch mal die Demo im Hintergrund an, die Demo ruckelt, seht ihr das? Die Demo ruckelt.
Now let's switch gears to the next trend, artificial intelligence. AI has come a long way in the last couple of years. AI darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen. Yep, AI. It's not to the point where it's going to replace developers, but I'm sure we'll get there someday.
Wenn wir damit zusammenklicken, das glaube ich nicht, dass wir das erleben werden. Zumindest nicht in der Art und Weise, wie man sich das jetzt vorstellt.
Das ist by the way der Ober-Googler.
Chat, das End-Man-Video habe ich schon gesehen über Halo, aber das ist auch gut, aber das geht zu lang.
Die Weller passt, die Weller passt, die Weller passt.
Okay, also wenn das die Trends 2022 sind, dann ist ganz schön viel Zeugs, was mir am Arsch vorbeigeht, Trends in 2022.
AI Wahrsager.
Okay, also quasi AstroTV als Web 3.0 AI VR Service. Exzellent.
Ist das so?
Ich würde sagen, SQL Databases waren eigentlich nie weg. Die ganzen Hipster-Geschichten um MongoDB, und hast du nicht gesehen, hat das ein bisschen überlagert, aber SQL an sich, wenn ihr mich fragt, war eigentlich schon immer so the way to go.
Marc seine Vorteile haben für nicht so strukturiertes Anwenden, wenn du keine Beziehung brauchst oder so, und einfach mehr oder weniger Key-Value-Store haben willst.
Aber ansonsten, ich fand klassische SQL-Datenbanken schon immer, gerade die Minimalform mit SQLite ist einfach extrem praktisch.
MindsDB, Pfeilfeld.
Moin Max und Chet, wo würdet ihr günstig den Server mieten einfach zum Just for Fun entwickeln? Tja, das ist ganz einfach. Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat, da kannst du dir 21 Euro Startgut geben, wenn du das nicht machst.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat, da kannst du dir 21 Euro Startguthalm-Code sichern und schon anfangen, ohne dass du was bezahlen musst.
Sehr laut. Jawoll.
Kennst du dich mit BGP-Rooting aus? Nicht wirklich, wir haben im Stream mal ein bisschen rumgebastelt damit, aber auskennen ist zu viel gesagt.
Server, da sieht man schon mal wieder, was für eine schwachsinnige Bezeichnung Serverless ist. Serverless SQL Server.
Ich mein, es sollte jedem einleuchten, dass es nicht Serverless ist. Du brauchst keinen Server mehr. Du brauchst keinen eigenen Server mehr. Aber Serverless ist das trotzdem nicht.
Altami Game Dev, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Im Prinzip, wenn man das so will, wenn man das einfach sagt, ok, du brauchst keinen eigenen Server, da war quasi früher Strato Web Hosting auch Serverless.
Achja, wer hat denn das gedacht?
Mehr JavaScript, jawoll. Gib ihm.
Ja, und jetzt hat man beides. Das ist tatsächlich ein Trend die letzten Jahre über, dass man auch schon prerendered Server, also dass man quasi die Seite prerendered schon rüber schickt und sowas. Ist natürlich für Suchmaschinen auch praktischer.
Und es geht schneller.
Es vergeht kein Tag, wo nicht JavaScript Frameworks erfunden werden.
Stimmt wohl.
Hat jemand von euch das Welt schon mal in größerem Stil verwendet? Ich wollte mir das schon die ganze Zeit angucken, aber ich bin nie so richtig dazu gekommen bis jetzt.
Ich bin auch bei Vue hängen geblieben.
Ich bin auch bei Meta Frameworks geblieben.